in the back clicks the
gamer is filming a commercial you're
pretty pumped you're in that commercial
oh
yeah are you texting your friends like
I'm in a clicks commercial no I can't I
can't oh [__] I'm not supposed to be
saying anyway I didn't say it cuz I had
a feeling all right you're okay so I'm
live so I'm live everywhere all right
wait but I'm not seeing that in the chat
here remember how we did it before 850
okay this is the most ever in ftic 1, if
I don't get 1,000 I'm giving away
nothing let's go nothing nothing I need
everyone here sharing hit share real
quick here's the thing I'm worried about
I'm worried that there's a lot here's
what I want to do tonight you guys have
we're sold out of spots here right we're
sold now we're not selling anything
right now we may sell something in an
hour but I want to get hyped I don't
know we may also sell something in a
minute anything's possible on this show
if you're just tuning in I'm Gary vayera
I'm
Adam rips head of Collectibles at
vriends best friend of Gary vaynerchuk
for four years and personal trainer of
Gary vaynerchuk and con man con man OC
operations and charm that's that's what
I got going con man brings charm rips
brings rip sing we're at
849 that's very good I see what you're
doing here dusto dusto you know what the
most ever on Fanatics live but it's not
good enough no it's not I business just
like I did before here right here's
here here so that's this is everywhere
else this is everywhere else yeah all
right so all these people right now on
like Liam Stamos and Louis olz and game
gamer reality and all these people on
these all the platforms they're not in
Fanatics right Instagram right these
people can't win [__] right so everyone
who's on Instagram live right now you
can't win [__] everybody who can't win
everybody on all these other platforms
can't win [__] and all I want to do is
give away [__] we're at 865 I everybody
at 865 flying Sushi 777 that's you Ron
bomie green dog you don't share enough
you know green dog doesn't share Ezra
like that one green dog I love your
passion 865 to a th000 that should be
very [__] easyy bro Jonathan 9 on
Instagram live I can't hook you up if
you're not in the Fanatics app I need
everyone in the Fanatics app and I need
you to create an account yes and put
your credit card in and uh shipping info
shipping info and shipping info you
don't need to use your credit card they
don't pay for giving at all you don't
need I don't need to we're not selling
it we're giving [__] wait real quick
there's 834 we're going down I'm about
to leave well they're sharing the link
why they're sharing they're sharing the
link oh you think they're leaving the
streen oh no cuz it goes on the corner
of your screen it wouldn't happen I
don't know go in the top right corner
right now share share share share share
share the share bear is coming back
that's a Wine Library TV character I
almost made a share bear be friend and I
should have Alpha Sher bear would have
been huge [__] what a huge mistake think
all right 8834 of you hit the top right
but everybody in here um that's in here
MJS like I need ogs in the Instagram
live right now I need ogs in YouTube and
Facebook I don't see twitch where's the
twitch Mafia in here where the twitch
comments twitch is Twitch fam in here
Dustin I don't see on restreamer Twitch
fam so I have to look at that but all
right I will do the giveaway because I
did say 700 so don't worry I'm giving
away a ton of free [__] but because
there's only one watching on Twitch
amazing we got to figure out what the
[__] going on there I need to really
understand the following a lot of you in
the chat right now do you have accounts
with shipping address and credit card
say yes set and no set in the chat not
yeses I need yes set no set yes set no
set all right a lot of yes set oh but I
want to leave some time for the no sets
because I'm giving away stuff and
they're not going to be eligible going
to be upset right everyone in the mix no
I need everyone sharing in the Discord I
need everyone in Discord I need everyone
sharing right now on Twitter Facebook
text a friend y I'm ready to give away
something and the first thing I'm giving
away is let's go I'm giving away this
Aaron Rogers Aaron roders Jets jersey
signed by me oh right now on the spot
black one I'm going right now first this
from the nation from the national
this is how it's
done j e
TS Aaron Rogers Aaron Rogers signed
jersey for
free shave his head shave his head all
right we're about to give away this
Aaron Rogers for free sign Jersey right
off top it's running we got 36 seconds
left it popped up hit the button it's
going it's going it's as live as live
gets like we're going right off the P
I'm just giving away away a ton of [__]
I'm in a weird mood let's go Abby I'm
excited as aby's working and watching I
appreciate that AB thank you so much uh
some people are conflicted as Pat fans
I've seen it please set up your account
get your get your name address it's
almost and credit card in the Fanatics
live um it's very very very important
you need to do that to get free stuff
I'm giving away a ton of free stuff I
need you to do it Zack Wilson all right
and here we go the side is large I
believe yeah large large it is a large
let's see who's the winner here who's
the winner who's the winner who's the
winner who's the
winner few more seconds who's the winner
who's the winner who's the winner who's
who's the winner Joe
MC oh my did he the flamingo the1 the
guy who got the flamingo what have a
night have a night have a night have a
night have a night there you go Jo to
jum
off the Gat all right would you say
you've signed over or under 500 Jets
jerseys way under way
under okay I brought something else
uh-oh guys we're starting hot an
original ink magazine cover with me on
it that's rightow I'm on it Inc How To
Succeed like Gary ve here it comes look
at that area right that area right there
I'm going to do it right
there Bang flip that [__] for a hundo
easy on the bay start it up go start it
up one minute on the clock I need all of
you I need all of you I need all of you
on these other platforms to get over to
Fanatics live I've shared the [__] out
of it links in my Twitter and Instagram
I've tweeted a hundred [__] times get
in here I need all of you sharing on
Twitter and Discord let's get this out
we're down to 603 what the [__] it's
like a 20% drop the [__] should we
cancel the giveaway y That's it out here
[__] this [__] wow here we go chat is
buzzing though yeah the chat is fire I
love it those who are here are here no
I'm I'm All About It 600 is amazing but
I really want to get people going I
think a little people are upset they
can't get it buy anything so that's
mistake we got packs on packs do we have
pins we have Halloween pins we do we do
I really want to open those they just
got announced today we' been aling it
we've been alping it here but it just
got to released today it really got
released today we should really do some
pins I think we should sell some pins I
really think it's important to us Z
Wilson ribs oh no cuz I thought it was
cancelled I thought it was cancelled
here we go this Gary B and here we go
Magazine first time here Jay White let's
welcome Jay White j j j white who won
this m Ranson
Ranson let's go M Ranson M Ranson Ranson
with a nice win I love engag with Ranson
on Twitter I was going to say you should
write that on it but then they can't
flip it on eBay if you write it to am
Ranson fair enough I want I think you
already made you already declared people
fli writing to giveaways is also pretty
cool I've got some other goodies boys
guys Gary didn't come empty-handed he
never does he never does I come let's go
I'm going to get oh this is cool I'm
going to get people's juices going watch
what I'm about to do what's happening
there that's how that's how we look this
is the desktop version but I don't know
why it's frozen there it's just no
worries all right all right Frozen are
people frozen are people frozen on the
desktop no good no I love how fast it
was like it's there's a no lag not for
us okay we're good all right don't worry
about that that just might be us want to
see more of this yeah I just I just
that's fine I'm good with this what I'm
worried I like it better it shows us the
context what I'm worried about is I
think people want to buy some
stuff I I think that I want to give away
stuff
and these 657 people are with us tonight
they deserve what I'm about to
do no oh my are you kidding I'm dead
[__] serious I told you I was going
to be serious tonight this is a 10 in
the new label I'm aware this is a
[__] 10 you're going to get this in
the mail regr it I know it's $2,000 and
I'm [__] here you're actively looking
to buy
these I know you I'm dming someone right
now the bicep about buying two of
them it's the only goat you have is it
the only goat I have yes no it's
not it's not up yet it's not up yet not
yet put it up it's a cgc 10 I told you I
was coming serious tonight and I'm
coming serious it's like a Grail this is
this is [__] serious I told you I was
[__] serious Give It Away con man
let's go oh it's the rarest it's the
rarest character in the whole set Chad
is going crazy come on
now now to remind everybody this is the
old label cgc cuz I got this originally
this is an absurd this means it's a now
a 10 you will get this it's legit two
grand that is all right
relax
relax relax oh look it's your only one
it's precious I'm going to buy it back
whoever gets it for two grand like it is
what it is like the bottom line is I
want these people to be excited happy
birthday to son I want to give the
birthday boy the four-year-old a happy
birthday went too fast bring that keep
bringing that back up let's make sure we
give a big happy happy
birthday um my son yesterday uh Benny
Benny what's is Benny Rhino's B 1985 son
Benny Benny happy fourth birthday wait
till he get to five all right here we
go someone is about to get farewell this
REM ready farewell Z Wilson here we go
here we go here we go if you're just
joining for the first time every time
there's the biggest card we've given
away big the biggest card we've ever
given away it's still coming it's rol
aexting as Conor
says Bill 824 no way Bill he's a big
supporter he's a big supporter you're
happy
happier he's happy CLP it up for beta no
it just came in go watching beta R it
would have just came in bet Ray with a
big one I'm not done oh my gosh this is
the rarest character in the whole set
that is insane out of 555 and only 277
are like this cuz they alternate poses
that was pretty cool actually no stop it
you only have one of these there only
you only own one of each it's it's our
historical collection we're going to buy
them later I promise people tonight was
a big night this is a s okay it's like a
sample first home
graded we're giving this away now I told
you I was coming in hot
I'm excited I'm giving away
stuff yeah I'll be on eBay tonight
buying more to restore the be friend's
curated collection how many people in
the chat cuz there's a lot of new people
have no idea what a super sticker is say
no idea in the chat say no idea if you
do not know what a super sticker is look
rips instead of complaining and
crying look what's going on there's an
enormous amount of new people fine is
literally hundreds of people have no
idea because we're growing now we're 76
we got to share everyone top right
corner share this stream get your
friends call your grandma say granny
we're live get on [__] Fanatics live
Gary B's going [__] crazy granny get
on Fanatics live Gary be's going crazy
I'm about to give a trip to [__]
Hawaii why not we need more in the we
how do we drop from 800 plus we're doing
fine we're building up now all right so
we're giving this away what are we doing
give it away give it away we're waiting
we're
launching I did is for kicks and
Giggles it's live everyone enter baby
tell tell them how they got this tell
them how they got this let's do we have
a shoe in nearby everybody real quick
rips can you please you're the straight
you're the information man tell them
about super stickers how they launched
at the national how they got to go to
how they have to go to vri.com
cars how you had to buy a pair 500
entries let's go got you a free coffee
got you got I took the other you got to
educate rips you're not be super
stickers not here to yell and cry you're
here to educate super sckers KH is here
to be charming and do Logistics you're
here to educate I'm here to be special
vend super stickers Prismatic super
stickers emblematic of the early days of
Pokemon card collecting outside your G
your grocery stores these prism vending
stickers we made them to launch at the
national but we have 250 characters in V
friend 51 characters in series 2 yeah
more I'm focused about Zack
Wilson [__] missed it let's see who wins
this they launched at the national in
the promo VIP bags people went crazy for
them at the show after that the next one
there was 19 characters after that the
aspiring alpacka people are asking how
to enter DJ read oh DJ DJ D dgim I have
to have myone
DG yes
Katie Nick I need a glass of wine I'm
ready to get going here we go here we go
these guys you could only get this they
were pregrated from cgc if you bought
the aspiring let's take let's take a
step back and educate there's a lot
going on go to Ebay completed items
right like a lot do you know how many
people have no [__] clue what the
hell's going on say no clue ladies no
clue in the look look at us rips I need
to show you no clue no clue no clue now
for the 300 of you that know better in
this chat that are OG's I need you
educating in the chat I need you to put
vs.com people are selling the photo
people know what they're doing they're
selling on eBay from Fanatics
live that is too funny I just got a text
notification Nick what do you need which
was your favorite from wi any is fine
thank you so I just got a text see do
these do those links work yes are those
linkable yeah can't click it I'm in oh
that's interesting and your your maybe
on desktop oh we we don't do we have a
section where we can make things
linkable here's what I would say can you
guys do some homework I want some of the
ogs to have the ability to link so that
they could be the ones that entertain
excuse me educate thank you my brother
all right the wine is now look at that
gritty ghost nine we gave these away
like butter ready 51 bucks this wine
we're going to refer to as Remy Remy
like Remy Martin and the Remy is about
to hit the
system okay and when the Remy hits the
system there is no
telling rips is so young okay here we go
75 bucks for these n95s that we're
giving away like left and right left and
right where's our community stack I
might have got I'm reading the chat
people are asking we the four five in
there I get it like you know Jesus you
know yeah bro I've been putting it
together that's very feel
it all right here we go w
here we go I I knew it was going to be
decent but that was way better than I
expecting bang freak right now give it
away give it away give away and watch
this Bang free right now this is better
than this this is probably the same as
the skeleton 110 it just sold e sold for
110 show them show them everybody who
doesn't know what the [__] going on
watch ri's phone right now look what is
going on on eBay understand what
is9 140 on the best off understand
what's happening in friends we are
trying and will be feverishly trying to
build the next Pokemon the next Magic
the
Gathering Hannah you know remember in
high school when you like weirdly
started thinking a nerdy dude was
attractive when a year earlier you
thought it was nerdy like freshman year
he was a nerdy but then you're like wait
a minute he might not be nerdy looks
good I told you those nerd dudes
sometimes glow up and remember when he
was like playing Magic the Gathering in
Pokemon your like nerd life that's what
we're doing here that's
Adam no
no he's getting look look how red grips
can get look at look how it's happening
in real time I just felt your boob live
on
[Laughter]
fanatic live live like Zack Wilson
[Applause]
baby let's
go come on chat all right let's go chat
bet Ray I see
you look at this we just hit this we hit
this last break 120 bucks oh we hit that
last break wait adley is a dog adley is
a dog adley is a dog I guess what is
that a raw show them this raw show them
the raw
raw 120 bucks right did we just give
away the winner raw 120 bucks is
everybody ready for this right in your
face bang Gary own too don't forget it
Lord adaptable alien take a look at this
see these are Gary originally owned what
people don't understand is if I keep
doing things right there's an ARB on
that look at that look at this one that
sold the rarest super sticker didn't
that go for, 1500 yeah 1,500 bucks Jesus
all right black I'm just giving away
[__] I don't know if anybody's paying
you got it y just put [__] alien go
it doesn't [__] don't get crazy with
me 2022 always does it takes he writes
like a [__] Warren you have to learn
the lesson the thing just give the F
just call I just want to make sure every
call number seven yes yes all right but
that way we get we got get the package
can you please explain stuff to people
like they don't know what's going on
here people are lost Hannah's confused
like people are confused I do not think
the community is doing a good enough job
onboarding the new characters to our
community I don't even know what's going
on with Dustin's computer here it's like
went to sleep I don't even know if we're
live we're definitely live I don't know
what's going on here you can't
see
all right V friends has a bunch we're
we're pretty established in the card
world right now we have series one cards
though we don't even see these on the
listing they're that rare hold on did
people subscribe to the channel is
everyone subscribed to the channel say
sub yes sub no I don't even know if
people Zack Wilson is coming in three
seconds Z
Wilson the Remy is hitting premature
sacul premature sacculation it's a pre
your ex aculation I like
that that is what they are offici mg 99
mg mg 99 mg 99
mg9
m99 M Dam I knew it I felt that was I've
just been scrolling we're only at the
beginning of October I've been scrolling
4 minutes that's how many sales there
are I need to sell something we can
auction something we can auction I like
you haven't done that yet done an
auction what can we auction that's up to
you everything we have a pin
box going to the office no my phone with
and I've got numbers I've got get
someone on the stream I've got I've got
numbers I've got real numbers I've got
real numbers we could do stuff I could
sell this phone Adam rips face Adam rips
you have ad number I got real [__]
numbers I feel we could do something cuz
I got numbers I got selling auctioning
phone num on Fanatics live I've got
stuff I've got stuff Anthony scaramucci
Alex log
is I know bro I got a lot of [__]
phone numbers whose phone number Chad
whose phone number should we
auction whose phone number would go
crazy I got a good one a boogie I got a
good one Andes Zack Wilson's ASAP
F
what
yeah all right Jeff gold blo Aaron
Rogers s Garner Andrew Schultz Snoop
Dogg all right what Jo bid what should
we do what should we do someone said
Mike gii sports car nonsense let's go
all right I want to calm it down let's
get it quiet we're about to do our first
ever
auction what if I what if I took this
you're giving away one of ones do we
have Andy no no we only have that we
can't get this in China maybe in China
though you're asking about like is there
another one in the world Andy we decided
against it we're good don't come here
I'm gonna I'm gonna auction off
something big something real big I'll be
right back down give away something all
right give away something and I'll
educate you educate while we give away
all this wow holy moly four 9.5 this is
like a few hundred Innovative
Impala guys I'm going to go high level
while I have uninterrupted 30 seconds on
compete and collect it's live too the
giveaway is live confine collect is a
trading card game with the vriends
characters it's 251 characters every
single character has a score from 50 all
the way up to 75 players battle back and
forth head-to-head just like poker kind
of with aura skill and stamina to
collect those different points the first
person to acquire seven points wins they
go back and forth oh I challenge Aura oh
I accept I have a 21 this one beats the
20 they win an aura point if you get to
seven points in one category you win
within this set we're tracing we're
chasing three things we're chasing high
scores so there's 75 perfect Persian cat
72 73 74s you're looking for high scores
you're looking for rare characters
there's short printed characters 10 of
them that are the hardest to find we're
looking for those and we're looking for
Rarities so the foils it ranges anywhere
from out of 500 like this to six
different one of ones autographs
original art inserts and more that is
compete and collect that was actually
really well done props to me I hope that
helps some
people zero the winner of four slabs
four slabs
a lot of Poker Dynamics innn wise wasp
YOLO yakin andala all Gary originally
own 9.5 a lot of strategy let's go Chad
is hyped who's winning who's winning
tops add TOS adct wow fun fact about
tops addict these cards were created by
Fanatics a lot of people don't know it
zerocool VR is the first ever
collaborated with zerocool these are
made by zerocool the Fanatics card
company for entertainment and culture
tops addict with the win all right you
ready uhoh so we're going to do an
auction we're going to do an auction
I'll warn you that sometimes it happens
sometimes before we go live for your
education people bid sometimes at the
end we get like a flag on the play when
someone's card gets declined last time
they had to call the bank called them
right away and we solved it and we
actually sold to them live but sometimes
there's like people don't have the stuff
set up right and it doesn't go through
so you might have to run it once or
twice this a pretty big auction I think
all of you are going to like this
because even if you gotten have not
gotten into the adfs or the cards
there's a kicker oh
no kicker there's a kicker so I'm going
to whisper to con man like Greg the leg
what to what to list it at 2000 and at
p.m. welcome to the V friends live
stream ASMR back opening okay all right
yep okay yeah I forgot again can't ASMR
this I need every single person to go to
the top right corner and subscribe
subscribe to this Channel and share this
channel get people on right now N I need
everyone to put their address and credit
card in you need the credit card to be
eligible you don't need to buy anything
I'm giving this away for free but I need
everyone to do it well you're auctioning
aren't you I'm auctioning this yeah but
I need oh right I'm sorry you're right I
apologize I'm auctioning right after
this auction because I want to test the
auction feature this is for the hardcore
OG collectors you're going to know what
this is but there's a kicker and it's a
kicker that I get asked
for
300 times a
day a 300 time a day
kicker that's right no no here we go I'm
going to do extended bid are you ready
so when it gets under I don't want to
look when it gets under 15 seconds under
10 seconds and someone bids it resets
the T this one okay that's fine so what
did you just say the I'm assuming the
bidding Conor Conor is the bidding
starting at a dollar or are we starting
at $1 with extended I'm about to give
away this
it starts at 15 seconds it's going to
get under 10 every time someone bids it
resets to 10 seconds that's how these
work until it ends Alex Victoria Katie
Nick pay attention oh no this is gonna
be nuts the following item is for
auction post
it it is a perfect Persian cat
nine rare but the kicker is you also get
15 minutes with me oneon-one
next week on Google Hangout to pitch
your business look at Hannah she's upset
she knows I don't have the time it is
not only the card which is worth a
[__] fortune yes but 15 minutes one
on one my gosh me and you now if people
understood what these go for at charity
auctions this is an opportunity to not
only get one of the best
cards but a oneon-one could be an art
honestly too so we're done what's
happening with the auction I know
nothing so it's Gonna Keep extending it
it resets it resets 2400 2500 28 29
3,000 yep are you ahead of us no
slightly 31 32 34 how much is my kidney
worth my God I'm pretty excited the 15
minutes you can pitch me your business
we can do your podcast I'm in
wow You'll have to you'll have to uh
declare you'll have to disclose on your
podcast that you know you won this
auction
uh so I like transparency but we are
auctioning this ridiculous card one of
the best cards in my collection cgc N9
which might be a 9.5 now I'm not sure
but it might be 95 it's an old label old
label yep 41 that whole Miss squir cards
all right four three 41 4200 eat with
Mark hey we can drink wine on Zoom
together 5 Seconds you can have a big
staring
contest 4,300 Justin Aspire there's a
lot of BS in here this is going to be a
lot of bids so this is going to go why
don't we take time while this is
happening y to educate people how many
people here oh it's almost over4 it's
over it's over y okay I completely
miss somebody [__] stole that let's
go Justin wow it went through right
we're good 4,300 bucks There You Go
Justin
congratulations what's his name that is
huge Justin aspired and you'll be a get
you'll be able to connect KD and set it
up y we'll get their Justin we'll get
yeah make a big reminder on that J I'm
going to work really hard just to make
this car day in the next 5 to 10 years
and I'll see you next week for 15
minutes k go got it amazing all right
let's keep this going with giving away
this Zach Wilson this is big right now
auto rookie card for free for all of you
for free let's CH it up free free free
free free free free free free free all
right everyone here has a chance to get
this free this free launching launch it
launch it I'm super excited what's this
worth right now ballpark I don't my
brain I mean the last week has Chang
saying I said right now this is easily
three three plus 300 plus I'd say
definely not no yeah contenders is Big
yeah contenders 75 here's the bottom
line it's actually free for somebody
part of the vri's family yes or Fanatics
live family or but now they're vends if
they're here they're vriends family
there's a lot of people confused though
rips actually after this moment let's
comment down let's take a sip like four
times and then we just amp it back up
can we where where are the pumpkin packs
where the pins it's a sealed case right
below us yeah we have Cas let's do it
let's get let's get one open but rips is
going to describe things like I need the
I did a really good summary while you
were gone I was where's this whoa whoa
you got a con man yep all right can
someone help the con man someone just
got a steel thank
you if we just drag this under we'll
slice one of one vampire I saw the
oneon-one vampire was watching mon
monster
monster like Zack Wilson damn it Zack we
missed the Zach Wilson on the Zack
Wilson Oh Conor was hit it Connor hit it
the winner number
two number someone said sign it that
would be weird but you can sign this NF
ktie oh Katie yes let's go Katie Katie
kti
kti K all right K was one of the only
the only be M like hardcore V member who
came to the London card show to see
friends when love her I'm a huge [__]
fan that's a huge win all right let's
reset for the 800 people in here first
let's share text your friend call your
grandma put it up share it Jesus oh jez
get the link in the Discord right now
please hit up everyone don't worry about
that let them ezrael will open this up
pass it to the youngsters we got nothing
but good-looking youngsters behind the
scenes let them open rips con don't
worry about them s can do it the back
please explain let's do
this let's do this how many people here
are utterly confused please in the
comments put confused you don't know
what's happening in the be friend's
cardboard world look yeah Beyond look
look we need more y all right just early
in the process good also good answer
rips
calmly I'll do my best to stay calm as
well calm CL for two three minutes just
give an overall feel of what's Happ
Happening
Here vriends go to vri.com
all right real quick no [__] every
one of you put vri.com
cards if you don't get the information
from here tonight you will learn a lot
through vri.com cards we launched an
nftd project which is a Pokemon meet
Sesame Street IP about two years ago in
nft form we've expanded I drew them
we've expanded into Trading cards the
game is exploding I'm super excited
about it pins are huge super stickers
are huge these boxes are huge but here's
the problem OG's if you're an OG and
have been part of every stream put OG in
the chat watch this
OG's look how many OG's there are so
many people entering all I hear from the
OG's is like we need more people to know
about vprs we want more people in be
friends friends we're committing a lot
of time these are evenings from family
from work please OG's there's so many
new people coming in constantly refresh
and educate constantly hit them up say
who doesn't know what's going on do it
one by one rips we're busy here you know
sent the text to 4,000 oh you just sent
it just I got yeah it's going right now
I Gott you just sent it I got it amazing
so we're gonna have some be friends
coming right now we just sent 4,000 text
to the V Friends Community so excited
for them joining but here's the thing oh
ge's I'm looking at you I really need
you to step up you need to be active in
these if we don't
educate we don't accelerate yep all
right the word and so vri.com cards you
have to share it link to you know push
them to my Twitter but the core things
in be friends Collectibles land for
everybody's joining me from all my Gary
ve content from my textt for my social
the core Collectibles as you know I love
collectibles in that game are the nfts
series one is the OG
I've been watching people who got into
the cards here saw yesterday bought a
first bf1 y the nfts then the trading
cards then the pins and the super
stickers those are the four core things
we got toys we got merch but those are
the four that we focus on on Fanatics
live here please connect your credit
cards and your address if you want to
win free stuff do not buy anything on
this show ever if you can't afford it do
not buy to speculate do not buy anything
on this show with the thought that
you're going to get lucky and then flip
it on eBay that is
highrisk reward at times but very
challenging too many people do not spend
a dollar you can't afford to lose
collect it if you love the characters
we're about to put these pins up these
have not launched yet we're launching
them next week Y at ComiCon we put up
the blog post today be friends OG's in
the chat please put the link to the blog
post to all the information about this
these are pretty remarkable because they
have a super sticker and hold on um I
think you sell too
cheap I don't want to sell them by the
box they're per pack in here right yeah
yeah we could also do something they're
50 of piece inside right yeah we did
something fun yesterday we did a pack
and a CNC in one of these which is fun
no let's just 50 should be we're doing
these a 50 right and there's going to be
bunch of available and they're going to
be available at ComiCon so we should go
50 maybe a $5 tax a
$55 you know like
right and I get to sign it so that could
that adds to it so we're going to go
these at 55 okay everyone who knows how
ftic live Works how many are in here 20
10 10 10 each 10 so 20 I was right you
were wrong there was two you two were
wrong I was right we're going to put up
20 for sale at 55 bucks a piece right
now for a lot of people that are just
joining obviously you've all been there
for free now you'll be able to buy
something you'll get a super sticker and
a pin if you know anything about super
stickers we really excited about this
but for vriends holders take time
you hooked them up I hooked them up big
yeah if you read the blog post please
link the blog post I see so many people
are doing
this okay that was the
Zen you're working on a con how you
feeling working on it good all right yep
you feeling good yep let me see what's
happening I'm reading we will do more
giveaways somebody just said we need
more giveaways good news more giveaways
coming we're g to bang these out the
reason we're going to bang these out is
I'm [__] obsessed with these and I
want to open them and see if we get a
super sticker that's crazy including one
spectacular in every case at least and
can't we get the cat yeah but that would
really be interesting that piss me off
right me too it's like when you open the
first box is Zer you got skch you're
like but there was 15 of those only one
all right I want to read stuff you're
welcome let's read that's right that's I
just saw somebody educate somebody it's
like Pokemon meet Sesame Street right
that's the IP for the people that are
just joining great job Tina thank you so
much for educating Dustin F thank you
for putting this up as OG's tonight is
the night we make a we make a
deal if you're an OG and watched every
stream and have been part of this
journey and you're ready to make a deal
with me please put deal in the comments
I need you to put your hands in here
boys we're making a deal tonight get on
top bro what do you mean
yeah all right we're making a deal
tonight all right the deal is this going
forward we educate new people you as
OG's not prompted by these two guys you
as OG's in this chat you jump in and say
who's new who doesn't understand who
needs to be educated yep and you the ogs
will jump in and educate as we expand
this so that these guys and you two will
do a better job you've done a great job
people have really liked you but you
haven't done these breaks to set the
context you just assume that people know
who the [__] radical rabbit is but they
don't do you understand I do okay so
we're making a deal tonight I do on
three one two three deal ready one two
three deal let right
all right that's it so I need that so
we're in the deal are we ready to put
these out yep we're going to do all 20
at once all 20 at once we're about to
sell 20 spots for $55 a piece these will
be do not buy them unless you've got
like the hunger the added Auto is adding
the value I'm going to Auto the boxes
that we sent to you but these will be
$50 not 55 like we're going to sell it
for soon but first they're going to be
sold to holders and holders are getting
a massive discount 25 bucks 50 PR it's
as it should be they should be be
winning series one holders series one we
expain smvs interesting o MCB has a wine
lob TV wristband I'll get into that
collectible in a minute you ready it's
up you ready to post he's waiting for me
no no he knows con man knows yeah come
on come on come on come on R come on
Happy 80 happy 38th birthday
crypto okay here we go is everybody
ready for sale I just want people that
are new tonight if you're new tonight
put new if you're new tonight put
new Victoria raise your hand say new
thank you all right there's a lot of new
people here's what you need to know if
this
goes if this goes the way it normally
goes this s what happened you didn't
impressed you impressed you sold it
bears are up 17
nothing side Justin Fields baby let go I
picked the Bears today did you in what I
think the Jets have a tough game against
the Broncos I don't think people
understand Broncos just have to had a
big we get off the Dolphins thing all
right everybody who's ready to buy who
wants to buy one of these 20 packs say
20 put 20 in here I want to get a sense
I love that I want to get a
sense okay so a lot of people are trying
to buy especially for the new people you
need to understand something this will
be about a hundredth of a [__] second
yeah it's been weird even no I'm excited
I'm humbled but I just wanted to not do
what before because I've been reading
the comments and people get upset so
I've done the proper prep con man is
going to click a button and it's just
going to pop up on your screen you can
buy right yep yeah on the marketplace
it'll show like one new break it's it's
a it's a game of f fast fingers so real
quick you just help people that are new
it won't just pop up in your screen I'm
actually not a trillion per sure we'll
find out but I think the marketplace no
I think it does I also don't have my
payment info set up because I don't
participate in anything Prett sure
there's a pop at the bottom okay you're
on it right now do you have your credit
card in dust okay good so I'd like to
see it actually attempt to buy no I
don't want you to buy it you won't be
fast enough anyway I know
how I know how you roll here we go well
you should have the phone in your just
show yeah just show it to he can hold it
up just show it to me I want to see how
it goes live thank you brother cool here
we go conman is going to press it on my
count one
two five good luck guys good luck
everyone there it is it's I think it is
at the bottom oh it pops up at the
bottom view schedule I think it's view
schedule but it pops up and that's what
it is then you go in there definitely
one of one remaining somehow zero yeah
no sold out yep okay and we're sold out
okay all right let's open them do it wow
Bill Bill guys first 10 next 10 it's all
randomized for everybody who's watching
all 815 of you we will be giving away a
ton of free stuff big shout out to all
the V friends that just joined us from
the text we love having you here
everybody Share Bear the top corners
here we go Ezra what do you looking at
what you guys excited about new be
Halloween pins DJ moow 30 fantasy points
in the first my son is going to go oh my
God two touchdowns 137 yards 137 be
friends Halloween pins there are 10 mini
boxes in here this a sealed case of 10
10 mini boxes inside you're getting DJ
[__]
Moore I know he's going
crazy that was such a good my man I love
you D best game of thiser let's go baby
first half second half magic let him go
for 250 gu how many points he has how
many he has 30 something I love it I
love you baby I'll call you later love
you all right I'm going to do 10 seconds
of Education V friends pins and super
stickers is the first time they're pair
I'll give education you pull up your
phone you pull up your phone and show
people vriend super stickers completed
sold on eBay because all these newbies
have no clue look at this look at those
first three that's crazy look at how
much money this [__]
is 200,000
[__] pokon this this one 1500 as I
don't need [__] laughing with a
[__] white
claw right look at that 660 the rare
robot 50 bucks 40 164 395 for a lot of
13 this the first time pins and stickers
have teamed up International we're still
waiting for Fanatics live to get
International capabilities we're waiting
for Android capabilities look we can't
do this on other platforms because it
has all these bells and whistles so we
have to wait we apologize but we'll get
to you soon oh jez what are the other uh
like more short printed characters
people think because of the uh
distribution of the packs the VIP packs
at National I think there's a few
characters like the red robot hold on
hold on is this sorted by no no no no
that's I want Rec oh that was SP that's
what I'm saying we're what everybody
please do your education don't get
excited about this do your education I
was I was scrolling it even the ones out
of $4.99 are 3040 bucks right now no I
know it's crazy Dynamic that one's more
like it this is the first time super
stickers your education don't get crazy
what I've noticed is a couple people on
Fanatics when they watch us go to eBay
and buy something without studying the
market and they overpay for stuff right
sure I don't like that don't say sure
sure like oh that's profound Gary
sure oh Andy do you want to come in Andy
you want to replace this guy you think
Andy will be more
enthusiastic at least more
respect let's open them up let's open
them com who's up number who's got first
first box mojo is BET raade Bill beta
raade yeah beta raade
Bill you're getting 10 pins every box a
2005 maresi de bolo bolo single Vineyard
I just did in the Gary vard 2015 thank
you uh in the Gary vaynerchuk wine ofth
Monon Club on wine library.com that
reminds me everybody type in
winetext.com right now if you are buying
wine on the internet and you're not
buying from my dad's wine text I hate
you no it's super simple like I like how
many people here buy wine in the
internet tell me where you're buying
from put the Doom in there I want to
read it tell me where you're buying the
wine watch these wine.com where they're
getting ripped off just cuz they don't
know I need to see where you're buying
from don't [__] a lot of liars
that's what I was going to say don't
upset Sasha I want to see where they
are a lot of people quick Creeks [__]
who the [__] was Creek they know what
they're doing that's a great [__]
Winery I love it wine text if you're
into
only grapes Flex music get the [__] out
of here with that [__] that [__]
[__] get the win.com right now sign
the [__] up all right here we go Bo
number one let just sign real
quick man I really want a big sticker
tonight this is the F every box has a
car a Halloween character 15 characters
only 10 boxes so you can't complete a
full set right away please share the
blog post about this launch today OG's
in the chat I see some of you doing a
nice job I see some of you [__] L
gagging like Ezra drinking a [__]
white claw as the chat may say you're
going to get a spine tingling
combination of characters you're going
to get the same character pin and
sticker match before I do these boxes
are is this empty where this
is I
just oh yeah you're right I different
put grab all right before we do this I'd
like to give away this for free nice to
the people that nope anybody got it yeah
we can do stuff I know you can cool this
is going away for free right now first
one of those you sign little Auto first
time I've ever signing the full box this
is going away for free right now it is
empty it is empty free empty sign I
think this is like a good $87 on the bay
sign these that's free cash you can buy
a [__] let's go it's live baby you
can buy fast food like four days in a
row easy on this right here free as [__]
here we go that's at least two
Chick-fil-A meals here we go someone's
getting this yeah maybe one Bojangles
[__] I'm on the board let's go
Bojangles all
right this one will save understood
thank you this is going away for free in
38 seconds very exciting you're kind
just going
awaye while we're doing
that not our first rodeo we can get a
lot of these what what's what can we hit
tonight that's super exciting
Spooktacular Red Devil glowing the
dark's ghost glow inth dark ghost um
everything's honestly really good cuz
it's pretty low printed there's no one
one there's the there's the black hat
empty sign box here we
go it's exciting I think we're going to
have to give away something enormous
though tonight you've done a good job of
that thus far enormous as Wilson Wilson
very good work Dustin all over it Trevor
Simeon I feel like we got to start
ripping once we see who wins the sealed
box going to empty box not sealed you're
right sorry sign box sign box Bor BD pH
Phenom been
tuning y he's been in here he's been in
here look at like that refractory little
feel to these boxes all right let's do
it let's go these you're ripping we do a
little pop the Spooktacular stickers if
you get a Spooktacular pin you're
getting a Spooktacular sticker people
keep sharing bet Ray all right I'm going
to open this here we go
please please please please share the
blog post CU there's a lot of newbies
here see who don't know what is going on
here you know what it is I know what it
is it's a [__]
motivated monster a motivated monster
first pin of the evening nice go look at
that five tattoo scar on his face purple
hat and the sticker bang sick out of
$4.99 it's got little bats flying in the
background Now remind me rips it all
motivated monster are $4.99 or no
correct correct the only one that's
slightly different is the every there's
one sticker per character got it put
them out the ghost has the glow-in-the
darkk variant which is that's the same
stick number two next oh jeez please
share the link to the blog post so
people know what's going on here Jackal
guys when you open it you get a little
bo I would have given you this one we
can do it nope we're going to give him
this one we're going to see what happens
here you're welcome Jack you see what's
happening Julian setting up the
emotion
The Jackal oh we got you got the boxes
right yeah we're all
good ripsy good luck Jackal
ripy oh ni One nice one that's one of
the rare ones it says on the back sick
comp
comptitive only 4% chance on that one
this a nice hit I think Vier was sweet
is the in separate or is it in the same
the competitive clown one of my favorite
characters also the logo for the pickle
ball team I own even though Ry hardwood
acts like it's his
team is he
here no hardwood is a part of all right
sir here we go this was the one I wanted
to give it seems like your clown was
better it's going to be hard for me to
beat the clown wisy guy all right here
we go it's a little pop and then when
you pop it you get that void cuz now you
I give away something so big tonight you
gave away awesome stuff that's
huge gi go was insane
let's go oh let's go probably maybe the
coolest sticker let's go wow that is
that's YZ guy YZ guy
96 fire sick the face of the
franchise the very very very very lucky
black cat is the face of the overall
franchise but I think everyone's
starting to understand what's happening
this month Halloween is big around here
we care about it we think it's a massive
mive holiday Global people don't
understand the global financial and
emotional impact of Halloween in
comparison to even Christmas it is
enormous and V friends is tripling down
on Halloween and the Jolly Jacko someone
say the face quadrupling some would say
very nice on to the next I want to thank
everyone who's doing a good job in the
chat Dustin F thank you for sharing that
America thank you for sharing the links
I'm excited here people are sharing the
information this is people are learning
on what we're doing here the blog posts
are in the chat Brett GM big shout out
to everybody on the other channels um
crypto Airborne I'm reading the YouTube
channels right now ironically please get
over to Fanatics get over to Fanatics
live we hit up the links thank you Bey
on Twitch sharing the Fanatics live
what's that I love that is that Kaye
that's awesome you're [__] amazing
thank you she's a real [__] twitcher
all right here we go this is Brett Brett
GM
GM you nailed a big one one of my
favorites Beauty the smooth spider can
somebody play Smooth Criminal by Alien
Ant Barm on their phone right now I need
it we tried play music and it doesn't
work too well but you'll hear it look at
this card I have to I'll show you
something on this one that you might not
know please tell me look at the uh in
the back it's spider webs and then
there's a little three put no doubt
spider webs there's a little three on
the webs in the back with the
spider web three smooth spider
smooth I always thought this alien and
farm version was out of
399 I'm excited about this who's up next
Conor the bisexual Barista big big big V
FR Fanatics life he's established
himself as a starting five that's facts
the Bice Barista the center he's the
center of this ftic live Squad and he's
going to be real [__] happy cuz
everyone knows what's going on with
Masters of the Universe OG's please link
it the Motu Masters of the Universe
Skeletor dropping tomorrow skilled
skeleton collaboration dropping
tomorrow in his office can somebody run
to my office and get the skilled
skeleton Skeletor collab this is a huge
hit huge hit wow we got some Skeletor
cards look at that that's sick look at
those skulls in the background this is
sick these are going to grade well too
which excites me but unlike some of the
early stickers we got the nice
backgrounds The Backs excuse me super
cool big mistake by rips by just putting
befriends
docomomo you take look at I'd be upset
if I missed that do you know sick this
box is do you know sick this
collaboration is going to be tomorrow
for everybody's watching if you know
anything anything about He-Man
collectors this is
monstrous the skilled SK glow in the
dark glowin the dark super well done be
friends Mattel tomorrow on Mattel
Creations $45
$45 sick crazy this is less than
this sick tomorrow's a huge day put that
back I don't want to lose it well not
for holders but yes all right opening oh
no I'm sorry put this comic in there
thank you so go to9 people go to
Mattel's website there you go
thought I would see something boom 14
hours and 41 minutes wow be there two
pack Mattel Creations we'll tweet that
out
May Esports Esquire is up right now
let's go Esports look at that $45 for
both love it they can switch heads
that's also
crazy we vibing we vibing like a vampire
vampire bam dang that's sick awesome
second vampire second big vampire the
night no the first one was the one one
was huge huge the vampire's sick look at
those red eyes that's some late night
white claw Ezra
sta right let's get it on pow who's up
next con man Sports Esquire was that and
now we're on to Matt expower
1028 which is very fun to open these
they sweet the packaging itself is
insane well the best part about this is
definitely the fact that the nft ERS are
getting such a half price discount and
First Advantage to buy and the fact that
these are going to crush
ComicCon next weekend it's GNA be nuts a
week from today a week from today we
will see you at the Javit Center which
is a hop and a skip from V friends HQ
right here can't wait to see all of you
V friends will be set up loud and and
proud I think proud Notorious BIG May
rest in peace the notorious
ninja this is a beautiful card great
this is one of my favorite cards yeah
it's cool and out of 299 personally
crafted Background by the vainer man yes
I I adjusted the background we had yeah
thank you I did get in there and I got I
still I said it I've said it before
notorious I think that this like of of
course we get fun but this could be like
the sticker background on every
character forever like it just looks so
good you were really proud of sticker n
proud of you ninja pin you both I messed
up with with corn the corn blows should
we show it we can show it that' be fun
you're actually live so if you want to
okay Tik Tok friends
um I'm actually live let me see some
names here Marco on Tik Tok Collective
on Tik Tock Remy
radio is on fire on the
Tock
J.M super original username on The Talk
Sean Edward Frosty Goose I like that
Frosty Goose you know what Frosty goose
is right I don't want to begin to think
about it yes show them the corny show
Tex this was the original this is cool
out this was the orol I still like it by
the way I still like it by the way I'm
sorry candy corn background on a super
sticker I think is sweet do you chat Hot
or Not hot or not this is this is fine
but it's show me mine again you're
getting a lot show me mine get plenty no
it's not it's not bad but candy candy
corn is polar did you already take it
away I it oh I made a mistake I thought
that was it but
it's but it's
the oh my
God that's number two there only the
rarest regular pin though I'm eating the
plastic I'm so excited we're giving the
Gary chw plastic away who got this
that's fine get rid of it who got this
this is [__] insane that is make sure
we know
that is Roman Roman Roman wow wow the
biggest he got some flames in the back
[__] I actually would buy this from him
yeah Roman Roman Roman you want to sell
this
Roman the rarest pen aart even it's as
rare as the spectaculars that's how rare
it is wow that was something Roman how
much I need this I want to buy that I
still didn't get enough hot or not on my
candy corn and then let's see what Gary
said R said I'd consider selling Roman I
saw you Roman how much brother a lot of
do yes Gary say can you guys keep an eye
on Roman's price yes so we can keep
doing this yep corn
blows show them the text show them the
text from me to you so rips shows me the
notorious ninja background working at it
yeah this is cool corn blows ghost makes
no sense with pumpkins we switch a bunch
of them show them show them the corn
blows
you're seeing how the magic but then you
change another one made you changed the
uh you Chang the devil right show them
the devil and then I'll show you your
text show the devil had the black hat
eyes peering in the back I crushed it
and then Gary said
um Roman said $50 in a new PIN pack
which would how much $50 in a new PIN
pack I think Roman's got yeah sold
thanks Roman that's done let's get Roman
another
all right that's done that means you
have to open another case fine I'll open
up like another case Roman thank you so
much for the steal uh let's get his
venmo information that's not it I get
confused all right okay Roman thank you
very much let's get him his $50 Shad is
going crazy okay Roman good stuff kind
of all right that was a good deal you
keep that aside we open one box for
Roman thank you Roman all right here we
go he made to deal with the arv that's
pretty Co cool even though that's a
trash talk deal that's like a $10
40-year-old wolven wolen blanket deal
this face off yeah let me just settle
into what just happened bang let's
go the well-connected werewolf this
reminds me of Hannah 6% well connected I
feel like Hannah could rip werewolf
Hannah you should come and rip one with
us let's go Hannah
should I should I switch with there yeah
get out of your just stay I'm I'm it's
going to be one get in here okay Hannah
you're going to
Pack's pop it up for
Hannah
Hannah oh hold on Hannah
relax
Miss
Han where you Conor you Hannah you have
put this why don't you tell everybody
what you do s at Boehner X how long
you've been here give them a little
context you know let's take a break from
fun and talk about business and
inspiration okay I'm Hannah I have been
working in some capacity for vayer X for
10 years let's clap that up 10
[Applause]
years and I'm one of Gary's Chiefs of
staffs
dad
Han up yeah give people insight to the
chief of staff like explain to them get
this crap out of here sonon explain to
them the day-to-day the speed the
intensity the work we're putting out
here we're not chilling no not chill
explain to them a lot of people are
confused Hannah you explain I I don't
know it's chaos but it's like fun chaos
and we're learning all the time everyone
that we work with is super smart and and
super kind who do you especially like
working
with um give some shout
outs I really love Christy mappis chrisy
very good she's very smart very smart I
agree this is soda dog by the way Hannah
need a husband Hannah's married you [__]
faces um who's your favorite
be my favorite V friend is the Puffin
the productive Puffin that's a great
that's a great because Hannah said
that because Hannah said that and I saw
this I am giving away this productive
Puffin for free right after this oh my
God hold this keep giving flowers we cut
you off y oh my God who got this sick Bo
The Fearless fery that is Soder dog
let's go Soder dog that's fire woo I
like the me too she's [__] epic love
all right can we set
up Hannah yes you sit very close to this
studio yes as we do all these things yes
you're very very serious and important
doing serious work dealing with
important people doing important work
how do you feel when con man and Adam
are just yelling in the middle of the
day while we run a multi multi multi
million plus Revenue a year Global
Enterprise
we're our Global Enterprise I like it I
think it brings levity and fun let's
clap it up for Hannah Let's Go
Hannah do not let Hannah have a knife
she cut you Hannah will cut you okay the
thing about Adam and Connor doing this
though is I can tune it out because I
don't even know what they're saying half
the time that's that's our mistake yeah
I need to get more educated Hannah do
you want a be friend yes wow no I think
I own three
whoaa no but one series one and then
maybe two or three series two a series
one do how many people here own a series
one vriend how many people don't say yes
no watch this Hannah yes no look I wish
look how many he knows look at these
nose look at these nose Hannah you are
in rare company no I wish look at this
you know there's only 5,000 World 5,000
owners Lu thank you Hannah for being
here let's you said I could open one
care go don't well I can just use my
finger push down you want me to open it
no no I I came on to open
it let's get under the camera do not
show the
camera you put this here very good oh my
god look what she did you can very
good you see oh my God H you pull a
spook T [__]
spook up up up up up hey
you first who got this who got this this
is Zen roster zen rosta zen
roster open it a [__] Spooktacular
this is the best one you only get one in
an entire case this oh wow show it wow
wow smooth spider the smooth spider
bubble gum 99 to
99 Hannah came in the C
pull the best [__] pack really yes
you're not just saying that to that's
the best one let's clap let's clap it up
Hannah One More
Time Unreal and the whole be careful and
the chat gets the skateboard because of
it all right and Hannah
came rips come back Hannah thank you so
much you should you should unwrap it and
sign it unless you only want to give it
away seals I think I should sign it
because then it makes it I haven't
signed maybe one of these maybe not even
so let's give this away
great job
hands I
got yeah I know I know but I'm just
going
to other side or not no
wow heart all right here it is and I'm
going to go ahead and launch it launch
it we're giving this away for free right
now we're launching it Hanah productive
Puffin what a call this is a perod
primitive collaboration skateboard
signed let's [__] go people want this
who wants this who wants this in the
chat let's make some [__] noise guys
here we go
[Applause]
chat here we go
chat
[Applause]
GPT this thing is so cool
get unbelievable wow what a
night this is
night very very sick skateboard still
seems like a shame that that gold sign
isn't gold sign isn't sign give me the
other side I'll sign them both sides
let's go both [__] sides there you go
you want the gold side it's Prime real
estate I get it I get
it there you go official super
official
get Z
Wilson Zack Wilson
and the
winner is of the Primitive this is nasty
this is sick this is sick is come on
baby red fish robotics red fish robotics
that's a new person never heard that
name
before red redish red fish are you new
red fish robotics tell us if you're new
Ezra keep an eye on it let us know if
you're new where' you come red fish Ezra
I'm going to use you because I'm have
questions for the audience red fish are
you new and where' you come from from if
you are well well done red fish clap it
up all right I feel the energy is fading
I want to get it up get it
[Music]
[Applause]
up is everybody subscribed to the
channel yes no right now I need a yes no
subscribe to the channel cuz that's how
you get push notifications yep yep I
think some people are no and if they're
no do they go to the top right corner
yep top right vriends logo press hit the
top right vriends logo and hit follow
you've got to do that this next yep Chay
get in
there you ready this one is for David
Who David
Who David who are you looking for here
666 I bet you we're going to pull a
devil right now we have 666 that'd be
nuts Wine Library really wants to know
what kind of wine you're drinking wine
Library 2015 maresi Deo Baro single it's
going to be interesting it's going to be
interesting cuz there's a variant all
right there's hit on the first stream
there's only 50 ghost 10% chance there's
10% chance right now doesn't look like
it no sir same eyes different GL in the
dark has the same eye color but that's
still sick still sick gritty ghost
gritty gritty ghost who got that ghost
David was David who hu David hu all
right can we give away something
certainly can does anybody in the chat
want me to give something away instead
of watching us open these pins real just
curious does anybody want something to
be given away we just the skateboard it
was I know just a couple seconds back
well I'm giving this away oh yeah oh my
Lord a [__]
monster I mean if you know anything
about me you know that I like being
passionate and this is a [__] parrot
who's passionate I'm passionate and
passionate parrot is passionate I'm just
giving the wh for free right now this is
what we do here we just come here we
hang out we drink a little wine we make
a little jokey joke we give give away
stuff we sell some pins yep
Melody we [__] this what we
do I think we should how we sold out 50
boxes yeah but before you even came on
can you guys do packs for future time or
you didn't figure it out
we can do it for tonight for the future
time we did not put up and you don't
really know what I can still do it I
know I I just feel like how many people
want to buy just one pack for how much
we can ship them packs no no I want to
buy they want to they want oh look yeah
but by the they'll get in their hands
before we were even to be ripping it
though because we can't go lie till post
ComicCon so we should just sell packs if
I mean I'm sure we can sell more boxes
we can sell more packs we can rip packs
here if we want to do actually to your
point it might be fun for them to rip
the P all right we'll figure that out
let's let's just focus on giving we just
gave it away we didn't say sack wison
[__] we were strategizing God
damn it people want boxes this is big we
can sell more boxes I don't want to I
know you don't we had a very big
conversation 275 RoR wash 12 RoR wash 12
wash 12 May knew Also let's see uh Ezra
rotor wash 12 are you new and where did
you come from Facebook the text maybe
new 9.5 on this one too could be rotor
text please tell us where you're from
rotor wash tell us where you're from
tell us your name new from Facebook
let's go let's go hey rotor wash and who
won the last thing the
skateboard um red fish robotics red fish
and rotor wash can you tell us if you
knew anything about V friends if you
know anything about our universe if you
have any cards if you have any nfts give
us some give us some info because we're
building a new family here a a brand new
family which is a lot of fun let's open
this open that for next one is
for Hof 247 H 247 you keep an eye Ezra
someone said I'm learning a lot first
time on said n till last
night I love the twitch family big shout
out to Twitch family cool X big shout
out you got it or me I got
it go it felt big that's the luck here
oh nice oh yeah Jolly Jolly
jao that's so cool it's that's one of
the beaut red fish robotics following
Gary for years we have three friends
Series 2 let's go by the way burn Island
big big scene swap announced right
yesterday not a burn Island but it is a
scene swap thank you bye tomorrow's
collab have the ability to change your
scene in series 2 to Snake Mountain from
Masters of the Universe how many people
when I say right now this are hearing it
for the first time but own a series 2
like our friend just now how many people
are hearing that you have the ability to
change your scene from your Series 2 to
a he-man Snake Mountain lot and this is
the first yeah people are not listen
you've got to follow V friends you have
to follow V friends on Twitter can
everybody please link vriends on Twitter
vriends on Twitter is the alpha is the
news you need to go to vri.com make sure
you're sign up for the email newsletter
we do crazy [__] free [__] upgrade [__]
and a lot of you have checked out
because the nft Market's a little soft
we're [__] working I'm
building I'm [__]
building I'm coming to ComiCon like a
[__] tornado I don't give a [__]
about a Disney or Star Wars or C I'm
[__] going in like a [__] Maniac I
don't give a [__] about your DC or
Pokemon or your [__] we're coming and
[__] V is coming and everyone's going
to be like what I don't know it good but
I'll see you in
2036 ComicCon I'll see you in [__]
2036 all right let's open this who we
got Bowser 0901 another repeat custom
Bowser I love Bowser little poke who's
coming to ComiCon at Javin Center next
week say me with a lot of ease who's
coming good job Tori lot e all over it
she was all over it is SC you're
up people coming we're still looking for
one more spectacular who's coming to
beon
2024 in Los Angeles say la in the chat
La in the chat yes Katie you'll be
holding it down trying to keep Glen
Curtis under control oh actually by then
you'll be doing content that crushes to
be Victoria all right smooth spider
that's
sick feel like I feel like everyone here
please type in Von Co in the chat a lot
of you need to come to the biggest pop
culture Collectibles marketing business
super business super conference in Los
Angeles August 8th to the 11th next year
2024 vcon
2024 I was gonna say jery NOS is in here
answering questions Jeremy I need you to
[__] hold it down Jeremy as the ring
leader of the ogs please Inspire the ogs
to put up links to tell people to follow
Jeremy like you could see what's
happening here the Fanatics there's 672
people here 400 of which are not
following day-to-day many of which are
buying their first be FRS pull up your
Ebay completed items on these super
stickers and pins and we need a huge
sharefest right now OG's share in the
Discord Twitter everybody share right
now we need some new blood in
here this is kindness wins 2
two great handle I think everybody
should be like aware of the drop
tomorrow for skele yeah I think we
should talk about that right now
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow is the huge
skele drop I I'll share that for real
quick tomorrow is the huge Skeletor Nick
get me the
collab uh please everybody share
creations. mattel.com right now actually
on the home page the homeage sick I'll
go back to the home page we need to
giveway I need to give away this is huge
this is gonna be huge tomorrow we have
skor not to mention if you buy I'm not
giving away my Skeletor rookies y you
know where I'm at with fictional
characters Betty Boop little Popeye Tom
and Jerry Scooby-Doo bugs I mean look at
this Garfield can can you like pull this
and hold this here real quick just a
little back it's quite yeah I know it's
up I got it I got it I got it look at
this I don't know what what are you
doing down we're good we're back look at
this [__] this is$ 45 [__] dollars
look at this this is [__] sick and
all the He-man people are going to go
nuts cuz that it's that design on
Skeletor and like the little comic like
we used to do noon
Eastern this is sick look at mattel.com
look at the skill not mattel.com Mattel
Creations you
dope mat.com let's see if it
works not at all football is back it did
not
work I love and a comic strip mini comic
strip rips I love you thank you let's
clap it up for rips we would not be here
without thank you we would not we would
not be here without him this amazing
this is coming out tomorrow 45 bucks
which is obnoxious I got yelled at for
making it too cheap I did it because I
wanted the Be Friends Community to be
able to buy it and flip it cuz I don't
think people realize how many people in
it's exactly what happened I want them
to win of course but the master V
Friends Community tomorrow's a problem
the Masters of the Universe Community if
you've been reading their reddits and
their social they're coming at this
because of the Skeletor in there they
don't give a [__] about our skilled
skeleton they're going to learn our
world you give a [__] about skilled
skeleton it's going to be a [__]
battle and I'm going to tell you right
now be is about to put a [__] whip
ass on M tomorrow it's only three limit
only a three limit I don't know get your
cousin to BU call your [__] grandma
grandma need you create a Mattel's
Creations [__] account need you buy
three cuz I need six let's go
Grandma Grandma's [__] buying that's
a fact though I'm sorry your grandma has
passed I lost all my grandma as well one
those wild one of those Wild next is
frison look at my latest text I was so
confused watching you guys I did sign up
Grandma who mom well it shows his mom
cuz it's my mom's contact I don't know
why does that but my grandma just texted
me God your grandma just signed up yeah
she just texted me that is
awesome okay before we go next one this
is free oh wow that's it I'm just free
just the Frog just put frog free please
yep not [__] write [__] Shindler
list
and come on just write the [__] frog
here we go I will side
it right off there we go here we go
Conor's list Conor's list is that here
we go John Francis you missed a ton Von
is here be friends are here Connor ink
it
up here we go who wants us let's go chat
we can still pop the next She's a Beauty
we can't who Bears commanders 2 knew it
picked them today I was right on
that uh so let's talk about this
actually this is what I should be doing
more of let's talk about forgiveness
forgiveness is one of the ultimate
strengths the forgiving horn frog is one
of my favorite characters on be friends
I do believe that most of you struggle
with forgiveness because you do not have
the humility and the self-esteem to be
the bigger person when someone has done
you wrong I believe that forgiveness is
a direct correlation to incredible power
Zack Wilson and I highly recommend all
of you realizing that if you are
incapable of forgiving if you canceled
if you're out if you're like [__] him
[__] her you are struggling internally
with your strength the capacity to
forgive is a direct correlation to how
much good you have inside think about
that ran 661 maybe it's Ray
Allen you don't
[Applause]
know by the way I think what I just did
there with the little St there's a
little bit right there's something there
we need to talk a little bit more about
agree let's give away this for free okay
let's talk about why I love this
character one of my favorite characters
in all of EV friends for everybody's
joining who's new if you're new please
say
new suffocate by the way new from I saw
somebody said my ex-girlfriend cheated
on me forgive her yes she was clearly in
a her place she maybe you were underd
delivering maybe the two of you in your
core relationship were under delivering
because you weren't able to communicate
the feelings you were feeling yes
forgive her CU that pain inside of you
is doing you nothing good my friend wish
her well hope for well you once loved
her yes she hurt you but you have the
capacity and strength to get bigger go
higher and still be able to forgive her
even though she did something so wrong
that's right you can let's talk about
this suffocate hate this is one of my
favorite characters giving this away in
seconds I I I think there's a lot here
if you know with peace salad and
suffocate hate and your relationship of
time we've created some memes some
statement characters I believe over the
next 30 40 years 20 years 15 years I
will absolutely build out these
characters and I love suffocate hate and
I love the story of suff of hate
with the suffocator the love and I'm
super excited about I'm excited about
developing this and I'm excited about
giving this out lot of good comments
positive reception look at that little
heart that's making
this Zack Wilson he's been a good job of
s doing a good job of suffocating hate
and I'm excited absolutely been really
strong he's done a great job I'm excited
I'm really excited to see by the way
this a 9.5 cgc if you win this resent it
to cgc you're going to get a 10 no this
is new label oh new label I apologize
I'm sorry thank you for fixing
Joker maybe J R is that a new name for
you guys y JK o r Ezra on it please tell
us if you're new where you came from end
your story with me or be friends please
give us a little something j k r we want
to know your full name where you live
let's get to know you know that's
another thing let's get to know each
other around here let's get to know each
other around here Andy get over here
real quick I want to show them your
shirt actually just turn this big camera
around to Andy so he doesn't have to
like break no cuz the mic you have to
take the mic yeah if i t m I'll talk
over it got it Andy's wearing a
shirt and people seen me wear this shirt
and I'm just saying this shirt is Alpha
that's it let's move on let's wait
for let's open this pack up next it's
Bradison
frison still need jko com need that JK o
r we want to know more about
you we're still looking for the for the
second spectacular there you go Care
thank you sir I like that that it's
getting a little bit deeper now we get
into like the characters we can teach
people y we also o nice oh this is big
look I'll be honest with you I think
like rare robot the collaboration with
Skeletor has put skilled skeleton in
another level I think I've noticed some
people buy up and 2 CNC is a great card
too that's I'm a huge fan of skilled
skeleton I believe in skills I believe
that skilled skeleton has elevated hey
vends OG do people agree with me that
skilled skeleton has elevated I've seen
some people pick up some Series 2
probably to get the Snake Mountain backs
yeah it's elevated skilled skilled
skeleton has definitely felt elevated in
our world look at this fire like I'll be
honest with you like rips I'm going to
want some pristine yeah I'm going to
want buy this on eBay let's pull up your
eBay right now rips while we're like
talking here there's a lot of people lot
somebody's talking about a fourth
birthday show complete take out super
let's see let's see what's F not super
take out super I'm sorry I meant this
let's see what's been selling
tonight um recent it's recent is it
recent beautiful let's see what's going
on tonight a little a little autographed
wizard wizard from the national look at
that nice heart Trooper for
$555 alien plus five shipping on these
look at this free shipping on these very
nice look at that little grenny goes
elephant well that's from FX live what
did you write oh number 10 it was the 10
one 10th Bo you wrote
boo I remember I told you to write Boo
or I asked you to write boo oh it a
little smeared interesting good well
still sold
it good deal play map went for 150 did
it there's the skelleton 110 that's
exciting let's see what's going on here
take out you can set up the next box did
we get the answer we Ezra did we get the
answer I just paint him in chat I'm like
where you
ated movie
listed pack of gold is fresh Ser we
Haven like series one cards are Beyond
rare and people don't know what they are
either don't tell them I'm buying them
all
okay primitive
deck I they're not for sale anymore but
they should be on eBay check eBay will
e oh that's a nice one that 55 it's
going
off oh that's a nice little deal all
right let's open another one forked
should we give away something for free
open it open it well we can do it's a
minute timer and I like
porked you want me to do this one you
said I did bring something
else good luck H come on pull
Banger you want me to do this everybody
there's 615 of you you've been
persevering and I Des oh my god oh it's
that's rare right I don't it's uh I
think so yeah 4% you're right 199 I knew
this was rare look at that like badge
let's go who got this HED it's like it's
like a badge this is [__] rare it's
like a badge DUS likes it a little
overlay Mak a little it's the Bold as
[__] bat to only
199 I'm loving that let's go honestly I
want this one too I need a pristine T we
have to do the deal we have to open the
other the other one for the yeah I got
the Roman we got a
let's payal Roman why don't you send him
55 bucks Roman's got to hit the eBay Sal
all right here we
go here we go I have some big news for
the 620 of VI I am giving
away can I look at
it oh it's a new
10 that's a new 10 that's a 10 pans are
rare big one you're being very generous
this is awesome I I told every listen I
I H all night you did I helped all day I
the Twitter spaces yesterday look this
is huge for everyone they're very
excited but I need everyone sharing this
right now on Twitter and Discord Twitter
and any Discord you're part of a lot of
you are part of the other nft projects
share this link right now in those
discords get this number up from 629 I'm
already giving away this I'll go higher
let's [__] support this is [__]
ridiculous I'm giving this away how much
would this be in a 10 in a new 10 yeah I
mean it's big definely at least if you
100 bucks definitely
100% 100% KH was like
yeah no no full conviction I look at the
show I think it's 400 it's also neat
like when the when they're blue they
know it's from your first ever
submission because we only have one blue
submission too yeah CG 777 I trust he
says 3 to 350 I think it's closer to 400
but I get it but in a 10 like these are
hard there's only 500 of
them I'm super excited I cannot believe
somebody's about to get this patient
Panda which is going to be a 10
when you resub it Z Wilson I'm excited
I'm excited the [__] we're giving out
tonight we weren't [__] around we did
not [__] around I give away my [__]
gift coat my only gift
coat and the
winner
is
damante heard Damon are you new
definitely by the way we went down to
579 I expect all of you to share let's
go
diamon congratulations you open the next
one I'm going to share and get the pump
up for the BL efh is that right yeah
Blaze oh blaz Blaze FH uh can you grab
my laptop charger I finally get to rip
one tonight let's see feels big feels
like a like uh here we go for Blaze
let's go Blaze come on now oh another
vampire guys we're getting duplicates
cuz we're opening two cases here out of
3.99 vibing vampire little
keep them nice and
protected let's go little bats in the
background vampire game for sure vampire
a follower from Twitter that hopped on
Fanatics live first time let's go
actually here's a good one who's joined
tonight just from Fanatics live like you
collect sports cards you don't even
follow us you know who I am probably in
some shape or form but you really don't
know much about what's going on here
where you might be into Pokemon and
you've been hearing a little something
Gathering cards magic someone just had
MTG cards are these all me like no no
hold on instead of me put completely put
completely random in here you've not
been part of this you've even maybe been
cynical to this you're not even sure
like you just got here put look funky
cool like I love this completely random
friends I saw I don't
know completely the Doon Ty complete
9876 what's up brother thank you so much
I love this like what's me friends found
you an only fans you're right skizo I'm
skizo I go on there and do real [__]
baby I get crazy on the
fans all right I'm the
fans all right keep going y JT tots is
up next JT tots JT
tots nft Loop closes us out JT tots and
N I was just say we have two left and we
haven't seen that second Spooktacular
but here we go this going to be the if
it's a spider we our last two have been
spiders I just don't want to SP that's
what I just said this is big we've hit
what have we hit so far we've hit the
diamond skeleton we've hit
three wait Diamond skeleton or bubblegum
Diamond we' hit three smooth spiders
bubble gums okay yeah if we've hit maybe
one other but I want the vampire gold
that's what I want it's the coolest is
Tom Cat watching he was earlier look
tomat this courage watching this is big
Spooktacular alert all right I'm
checking out who's actually sharing te's
in the building
what color is it I'm such by the way the
B is the best dude I [__] with him this
one oh
hologram light purple on that well
connected
world let's go JT who got that howling
JT I'd buy that graded I'd buy that
graded JT toss Cho of the dude CH C out
I [__] [__] with shared he has a
vending machine too mhm we can Riff on
vending for a minute got some vending
machines that's that's about it we got
that thms it
up last one nft Luke big Twitter
supporter big collector of stuff go I
think Luke was I think Luke was in our
first ever competing collect tournament
if I'm remembering correctly let's go
Luke good job Christopher everybody who
shares is going to get a follow right
now Christoper became your 48th follower
oh we got now Brian it's already good
but can it be glow-in-the darkk let's do
a sticker first cuz the sticker's the
same so the sticker is the same on both
of them let's get
crazy it's not it unless you're it's
going it also needs to be in the light
it's been in darkness for that's it it's
it oh my holy [__] the rarest pin in the
Box besides the cat one of the best pins
to get that is the chase holy [__]
that's the best thing one we can't turn
the lights off right show me no it still
be because those are on forever yeah we
can turn those off no it's not worth it
oh my God got it this is so cool they're
fresh I don't know if that works no you
can see it a little bit oh wow yeah I
don't know yeah I saw that I'll do it
again that look official there's only 50
of these yeah that's crazy we've pulled
two of them yep literally I really want
to buy one these are sweet what are the
eye differences so Conor oh my God
see sick they're [__] fresh as [__]
that is so sick who got that that is nft
Luke that was the last pack Mojo last
pack Mojo Spooktacular and
glow-in-the-dark back to back yeah
Luke's a good collector I think he was
at the tournament Luke congratulations
that is a massive
poll the other one has dark blue eyes
just like this this one has light blue
and it's also like a little bit of a
different material Scooby thank you for
sharing shaow oh meta Heros follow back
bang people getting follows right now
people are getting follows right now so
we have Jared boom got your follow we
have another blank slate we're we're
caught up no don't I have to open up one
more box that's right that means we have
to crack open are we all set with who
was it Roman is Roman still here should
we uh yeah Roman are you in the
building I made a good deal with Roman
I'm happy with it 55 I decided to give
him 10%
more Roman let us know if you're in the
building I'm ready to rip
it I'm feeling we're opening it we made
the deal that's true we'll just ship it
yeah I'm here he said I'm here you said
I'm here Roman by the way sending you a
surprise in your package as well got it
perfect I feel like I got a good deal
and I feel like for that Roman needs to
Roman Roman call the character Roman I
like how he said I'm here no crying no
whatever I saw the reactions for I'm not
sure if I got a good deal but I sense
that I did and so Roman Roman you're G
to get a good
deal he wants Jacko I'm gonna pull
it Matt I wish he got the [__] ghost
well let's see put that away we'll save
that for another
day I want something crazy you want me
to do this or you I feel like you have
to do it I'll pop it there we go Kyle
Express you now have a file follow
excuse me pyro you're in the mix lady
you're in a mix followed people are
getting followed right now by sharing
the Drew Williams followed bunch of new
people getting followed right now I love
it yep Kyle was already filed be easy
followed
got your PIN ready you can open it a but
it's your trade all right I'll open it
here we go for
Roman if it's a Jacko tonight was
fun Roman this one now was
gay he did it wow Roman [__] told you
bro I got
you wow you asked me to pull it I
[__] pull itow let's [__] go
let's [__] go Roman I got you bro and
I'm going to send you something crazy
we'll keep that one this is mine right
Yep this is yours the devil yep that's
yours sick put that put that on my shelf
with the Roman sticker on it with
scratched Out Gary put that nice that'll
be forever a little that'll be a little
funny thing in the back Nick put in a
spot that people can see with my content
Roman congratulations on the Jolly Jacko
that is epic can you sign my new box
says Roman
John M you should John M just got the
follow is that it yeah M got the follow
where's the marker I got I got
one Genesis Mara got the follow Fano is
always here Fano I [__] with you Bri I
[__] with you bro thank you sh how are
people getting followed right now uh
people are getting followed if they
share this stream on
Twitter what's happening so wait sign
Roman's box give him a little shout out
fresh
love that devil
oh
uh we're hooking up Roman we know what
to do we know what to do I'll make a
note hook up Roman we still had this
give away from the lucky character
before we got to give those away this
because we pulled five Bulldogs and the
te
get all right Roman I got note for you
everyone's getting lucky guys in the
group break from like 6 hours ago we
have the lucky character every single
time we pulled the Bulldog we added a
slab to a giveaway we're going to run
that right now for everyone in the chat
five slabs three NES 29.5s Roman five
slabs let me get this
rolling five x slabs
lucky shaow shaow sh we are live shapow
is a very underrated aatopia in my
opinion chat most underrated aatopia put
it
in what's the most underrated anomia
give me something shapow Chow blam Splat
bam rip agreed all right
relax Ching I love
ching shapow A lot of chaow cop
wow sheesh scch wow scch I'm giving this
away oh
shoot the other giveaway can't even
finish before we got another one ready
to go give these wow so comfortable
right so comfortable I've worn them
every single day since I put them
on look at look at that that's green
just like the Jets quarterback and Zack
Wilson
flush
this pair is going to be like look at
this look at this combo somebody's these
are size seven who won the really good
Collectibles patient guy 555 wow patient
guy 555 Pati and it's five
slabs there you go patient guy well
deserved he won all five that's it's all
all to one person at the end of patient
let's cap it up for patient guy let's go
do that something new patient guy 555
that's new that's new to me you got to
be part of the V friends world with that
username but
patient guy tell us your origin story
First Time In The Stream this and that
oh the box is signed the box now run the
Box the box is signed right there open
it up rips shapow blam blam Bing Bam Bam
bigo double signed pair of sevens this
is free [__] free I don't know that's
what I
do right people are getting upset that
we're all sold out we can sell PX ship
to their door or we we can rip some it's
just going to sell very fast we can list
either a lot of packs or boxes where
people actually have a
shot why a do starter deck we could do
starter deck shipped I think we'll give
them we'll give him the options four
packs give away a little PS4 give away a
little
Xbox does anyone use that
Xbox ever I'm tweeting something right
now everyone go check it out it's a be
friend's question how much attachment do
you have to that
Xbox not much
Jet's colors I always say I want that
Xbox are we giving away these
box everybody I just retweeted
[Music]
[Applause]
oh is it to many white claws I had one
white
claw what he break what he break glass
it's
yeah glass standing it's not the GV
glass though how about Z
the sneakers the sneakers sneakers
are malti tail says B Wells malti
tail that's an all time moment on ftic
live it was who's from Detroit a
Robinson a Robinson 412 new username
who's a Dallas
Fan Dallas fans in the chat who's a
Cowboys fan who's a real Cowboys fan we
have a considerate I don't think we have
a considerate Cowboy
please no Robinson with a pair of shoes
getting shipped out here we go are you
kidding me Aman Irvin oh 10 10 PSA
rookie cards [__] free right now in
the [__] spot Aman Irv let's [__]
go Aman I'm not
[__] bang bang combo wow combo three
cards it's not only about V cards on who
wants this it's not all about vs cards
on [__] V friends Fanatics live
October
comment yeah Joker can we get an answer
from I wish I had a considerate Cowboy e
you haven't gotten a single answer to my
question you broke class he's so drunk
he he missed them
all you're good good thing it's a walk
home smoking me with the
answers do you want to get us set up to
sell some stuff to ship to people I
don't know but I'm enjoying what's going
on on Twitter I enjoy the 625 in the
chat I enjoy our EB together as friends
Brothers contemporaries co-workers I
enjoy we've done some good things
tonight we've got to make a decision
right now do we wrap it up and close or
do we go hard for 54 minutes to 11: p.m
these are the decisions we have to
decide what's your favorite my favorite
fast food is Bojangles on the board of
Bojangles that being said I also love
White Castle and many
other um Z damn it I'll be honest with
you there's 6:30 here and I don't know
if I can get to 11:00 p.m. without about
700 I see people sharing on Twitter but
I don't think they're going to Discord I
don't think they're going to Coffee Kyle
coffee k k haven't heard of them coffee
Kyle's haven't heard of coffee Kyle
please tell us your origin story is it
your first time do you have a v friend
zft do you have V friends cards did you
find us by accident on Fanatics live or
on social who's ridiculously new please
leave a comment say ridiculously and
then explain how new you found us just
in the random Fanatics live or somebody
here tweeted and you decided to join you
know nothing about be friends I need to
know what's going
on the jack
pumpkin it's so good I was shocked Beast
it was so like uh I was just looking to
see if we had to consider Cowboy okay
I am trying to decide what we should do
next why don't we get some
recommendations in the chat what are we
doing next
here I feel like there's some stuff to
give away
I think that's
also Bulldog energy no don't you I'm not
giving this are you Fu that's a new 10
that's crazy you [__] out of your
mind it's crazy look it's basketball
season I'm double Nicks hading it double
Nicks
hat I like these I like this brand
actually I need to keep one single Nick
at I'm going to give this one away I'm
going to keep this one can you throw
this in my laptop bag to wear that this
Nick's hat signed Auto Gary B at least I
don't know 60 70 100 bucks on the bay
Nick's hat time here we go give it away
it's live it's live all time speed by
Beauty Conor put it
on put it on look ENT look at that thing
come on now can't beat it bang look at
fire KH bringing the Charisma and the
charm
con man Conor's lid who wants this hat
who wants who wants this hat I want to
know who wants this hat let's go it's
here chat who wants to take this thing
home right now this orang hat is pretty
fresh people want actually love the logo
on the front of this thing
beautiful people want to sell pins I'm
not sure people know about the pins
we're dropping them soon we got the
skilled skeleton tomorrow we got
ComicCon next week we got the lattes
going we got so
Z
Wilson if I don't get a Jets win against
Denver this week it could get
weird and the winner is none other
than we're looking we see Cyclone singer
Cyclone singer never heard of them yep
new new another new new new new new new
new new new people are asking to we sell
I want to get
people I'm always were selling stuff I
was like there's 70000 people here
didn't even have a chance to buy
something all right does somebody want
to buy something who wants to buy
something say buy I want to get a sense
it feels like people do want to buy we
just they haven't had the chance it all
sold out before you were here everything
sold out before you were here all right
so what do you want people want vending
machines there5 packs I'm saying I think
either we have we can I want where are
the minis minis I have a real idea we
just got a new shipment in today they're
here yeah I feel like we should sell the
minis that are 50 cents for5 bucks but
have a chaser that if you pull it then
I'll give you like a $1,000 card like
real crazy [__] that could be fun could
do the vending machines we got stickers
and pins you want me to get minis or no
I don't know we got the wizard
packs wizard packs National exclusive
selling wise I don't know about it these
are [__]
hot don't know about these packs these
are hot let me show you an example what
goes on in these packs I'll just open
one for
myself these were exclusive iive at the
national you get a common sense cow you
get an entrepreneur elf you get a hit
all the hits the peacock and this you
get the peacock and the giraffe but the
hit was a wizard numbered this was the
most
common are
fresh they've been selling really well
on eBay like really well consistently
too
MH I don't really want to give away I
don't want to sell anything everything's
going up like the demand is growing like
we got new people in the chat that have
never opened a pack before wizard wizard
goes
hard I just bought one on eBay this last
week pins minis packs people want
everything I would just there's 700
people who didn't have everybody can you
please post be friends.com cards for all
the newbies so they know
stuff single packs starter kits of five
but what's more fun than free give a
goose away from let's go that's very
gracious of you give it a little Goose
you guys free right a little [__]
Goose the goose is goose loose is goose
it's [__] free Abby and
live go
look this goose is cooked who's going to
get it juice is you know what's
interesting about this Goose it's going
to
come with the
worm independent glow glowing glowing
glowing yeah you think about The
Inchworm yep and you know what else is
going to
happen look if you want to be successful
in life bang you got to have common
sense now this turned into a fire lot
sheesh threepiece combo here 295 and a
nine and look she's as cute as it gets
the barn I literally believe the barnim
right the barn is [__] cute as [__]
four pack way too cute four
pack
rip dropped a nice let's be quiet for
the
last Z
Wilson never gets old who's getting his
four pack of [__]
slabs I'm getting weird now four pack
it's insane it's [__] just crazy now
here we go and and the winner head the
three
headss that's awesome they've done the
same thing before they won before for
sure well I like three heads of course
all right from all angles four cards for
three heads why would you like to sell
people want to buy but I don't think I
don't think we should sell for tonight I
think more giving away I think we should
sell for future events I can literally
go in and publish a future event right
now to sell for or we can ship it ship
them sealed product it's either or what
would you like to do sounds like you
want to ship sealed product well the
reason is because we can't go live till
after 1016 so it's going to be how much
pack 25 bucks yeah I think it's time for
they to go to I think they should go to
30 I look listen you know where I'm at I
people ripping stuff's going away that's
why boxes went from 240 to 275 if you
look at what's going on on eBay there's
not there's nothing and you know this I
don't want to give up all this inventory
I do know
that we sold too much for Gary's liking
last week I think pack should go to 30
and like that's just it and I think
we're deciding it live this is like a
business development meeting right now
now and only one purchase Oh can we
limit the purchase no but it takes it's
going to go fast like it's not going to
be like you can scoop a
100 we can list this Let's do let's do
packs for we'll just ship the packs all
right we're going to offer some packs
right now shipped one pack at a time for
you at home how many people here have no
cards put not yet it let me phrase stop
I know you're about to jump in I
apologize stop it how many people here
have no cards or no and are about to buy
a pack for 30 bucks right now please put
uh I'm going to do something besides not
yet uh please put 30 if you're going to
buy a pack right now a four a pack of
four of these hardcore gets
30 okay yeah let say um when you buy one
pack nothing you get a pack we Shi a
pack yeah but you have it's a $5
shipping and then every additional pack
is 50 Cent shipping they have like a
combined shipping they should be they
should be aware of the shipping cost I
see which is why sometimes two pack kits
for like six 60 cuz then it so they can
buy multiple times they can but they'll
probably go fast will we combine them
for them or no yeah yeah 100% yeah we
can at one pack that that's easy for you
guys in the end all right how many packs
do we want to put up for 30 bucks that's
that's up to you sir I don't want to
sell
them is it a bundle or how many packs
can you tell me how many packs you're
going to buy put X we have X we have 104
here so 100 is a put it out here like
put X there we go this is what I need X
X One X2 we could also list more boxes I
know that's going to be hug I don't want
to sell boxes
anymore all right let's do packs 30 pack
let's list 300 packs 300 300 packs let's
do it how is that easy or is that hard
um I we
do what
scrap um let me take a look here see
what we can
do no no no hold on what if we did
64 Slaughter like five of those should
we do two pack bundles at 60 bucks we
could do no a lot should we do two pack
bundles at 60 or should we do one packs
of 30 because I think a lot of people
only want to wipe one pack there's just
a shipping cost with it as all no lot
people want one pack one pack yeah yeah
let's do pack let's do 300 pack we We Do
50 at a time we could do 50 at a time
it'll happen in two it'll right so do 50
at a time 50 at a
time one maybe we give away a slab each
time to each group that could be kind of
fun not for I I want to sell this [__]
you [__]
jerk I'm kidding this is literally how G
works like you say it all the time but
like generous gift goat $2,000 one of
the best cards in the whole set free but
then I want to give away a base card to
everyone who buys it you're like
no you just don't even want to sell them
anymore like I don't think people
understand what's actually happening
there's no box there's no inventory
available I know and like we're just
starting this and like we got 645 people
on it 106 and like we just started I
don't think people understand like I
don't want to sell it when I hype
something and I ask people to come on
and give up their evening I'm going to
give them [__] $2,000 cards wait till
you see me give away this entrepreneur
Al for free I'm about to give this
entrepreneur Al away for free can we do
everyone buys a pack no fine assign
prices should I list the first
batch okay everyone I hope you're ready
for everyone who wants to buy make sure
your credit card and dresser in there
because this goes so fast you got 50
packs at 30 bucks a pack go
so this so G how it looks so it says 50
of 50 remaining and it'll it'll tick as
people buy so they're going right now
yeah yeah 36 34 it just it goes down
here I see and it shows there got it y I
think it's I literally know you couldn't
be more sad watching this happen dude
you know I don't I think these are five
I think these
$700 out sold out okay and there's so
everyone in the chat this is where we
did last say like say if you didn't get
a chance to get one and everyone just
like I'm pretty excited how many people
are going to open this with their kids
say kids if you're going to open your
pack with the kids say kids yeah see
that's that makes it worth it for me
grandma
Grandma
awesome I hate to we a [__] s
cards no
no oh we got to run this too yeah I'm
about to give away this entrepreneur
we're going to do some more packs
because I know you guys want to buy guys
and gals want to buy but I'm going to
give away this for [__] free because
no [__] we're
here
after who wants who missed out on packs
and wants this next match please put in
packs there's a lot of packs okay we're
typing away over here yeah all right man
I hope someone gets a oneone I just
someone gets a oneone black C from
tonight yeah there's going to be a lot
of bigs all right here we go ready go
yep boom show me launch it it's starting
now there you go it's up right here
5050 and down she
goes by the way I might go to 35 bucks
going forward no I'm serious I know like
it's I don't want to sell once do you
understand what happens when we're out
of inventory we're out of inventory yeah
rips doesn't get it he's like a Neo baby
with these cards he doesn't understand
like once they're gone he's going to be
like uh and he's going to go buy boxes
for 700 bucks what we do you know what
the plan is what are we going to do on
this show need to rip [__] I have
complete conviction that these boxes not
Financial advice will be significantly
more valuable I just think that in order
for that to happen the packs have to go
to new people and that's what we're
doing that's fair who's new and needs a
pack put new pack if you don't own a
single card and you want to buy one
tonight all right everyone stop and let
these new people buy one R's resignation
he's right stop and he's right we're
going to do this look how many people
want one new pack everyone if you own a
pack on this next 50 don't buy it if you
own cards don't buy it please let these
new people get a pack some who bought
their first tonight put
first there we go Timmy J John John
Carney didn't buy his first pack I don't
like when people do that Carney I'm
gonna ban you can we banj OJ's more
honest he I bought my 5,555 that's
honesty
it's probably still a lie can't be that
F the way you buy is you have to have a
credit card where' it go top right to
create an account yep probably you got
to create an account rips is going to
show you right now on the spot everyone
pay attention if you're
lost whoa what should I watch whoa V
friends is live this must be cool holy
smokes it's Gary ve Adam rips they got
Adam rips on the stream wow I wonder
where I can go shopping what is this
Marketplace IC
on it's a literally but what if they
didn't put their credit card in are you
putting you ready for next one yeah all
right this one's for all the new people
do not buy a pack when this pops up all
right let's see it unless you're new
go here we
go pops up it says complete my profile
of purchase that's what it says for me
but there it says just added 50 spots
now I'd have fast fingers I'd probably
still lose show that again cuz that F
The Market Place you click one because
there's a button there shapow shapow you
then it says uh 24 spots left then you
can press your spot and then when you do
it you'll be able to pay now just
doesn't have my info in I'm an honest
fellow I don't
participate Miami board ape let's see
let's see if we recognize people two
packs left we can re we can see if we
recognize people who have packs that
could be
interesting please do not buy if you
can't afford I see somebody said not
buying of course please don't buy if you
can't afford and you don't one painin
not working for makabe for most people
it is Batman Batman pack for soggy let's
go I haven't I don't
recognize guys it shows up in the bottom
brother everyone else here this is for
iPhone people it tells me my payment
isn't working what's guys you told me
something to happen with payment not
working refresh or something the other
day
Tyler I only recognize two
usernames are you setting up the next
one yep is this number 200 correct okay
uh please let's help
everyone please help everyone understand
what's going on
me chat we're putting up packs you're
going to get exactly what we've been
ripping tonight sent to you in one of
these in a bubble
mailer you're going to be able to open
it experience four new V friends
characters on your own you're looking
for foils like these guys did we give
away the elf yet or not yet yet right uh
elf no we have not given the AL away yet
you're looking for every character score
from 50 to 75 in a trading card game
called compete and collect where players
battle back and forth to collect Aura
skill and stamina you're looking for
when you open your packs this what
you're looking for one characters you
like that's always OG's please help all
the people in the chat right now that
are struggling to figure out how to buy
because we got the next batch going yep
Ready to Go yep one two three go this
not the last one this is 200 yep all
right do they come in the grade cases no
they don't please everyone please don't
buy if you own one right now we're
trying to get new friends into carts we
don't ship to Canada we will we can't we
got we can't right now we got some stuff
Brewing Canada Australia the rest of the
world we got a lot of good stuff
going what you're looking for when you
open these are one characters that you
really like hopefully you'll find some
of your new favorite ones when you open
your pack Pokemon meet Sesame Street is
the purpose of this that's a good way to
put it what's going on with the packs uh
there's 10 left all right you're looking
for foils you're looking for scores as
close to 75 as possible and there's 10
special characters that are a little
more short printed than the rest what
you really should do is say tag we're
very active on Twitter tag at vriends
cards on Twitter or at vriends on
Instagram and say here's what I got we
will literally message you say hey good
done here's what you got here's what's
good here's what's not all that two left
oh two one left so new people are
getting in yep exactly thank you
everybody for being so
gracious yep those are those ones are
gone so we're at 200 gone yeah 200 all
right let's see what happens here how
many people you're welcome Peter how
many people are new and want to buy a
pack put new pack in the chat because
I'm trying to see what's happening some
people are struggling with
payment new pack I want to make sure
because I want to get these people in
new pack no app no you have to have the
app you can buy online payment fix got
it all right people are fixing their
payment new pack new pack oh people say
if you didn't get it in time you're
seeing the payment issue kind of like
when you buy an nft it says transaction
failed because someone beat you to it
got it all right put up the next 50
everybody please do not I like how we're
doing this we're getting all new people
in agreed this is
epic and I I think the best really the
best thing they could do we like we can
really help them is tag be friends with
what you get on Twitter and we respond
is anybody a Dodgers fan and wants one
of these great Gary ve look at this T
what is this to 10 four of 10 Auto
Clayton Kershaw this is [__] sick put
Dodgers if you're a Dodgers fan I might
give big Dodgers the next next batch is
ready next batch is ready please do not
buy this if you've bought before let's
all let all the newbies in The Virgins
must
attack go vcon in La that'll be a cool
event yeah I should see recon.co you
going yep it's live virgins are
attacking let them in let them in let
them in they're about to lose they're
about to get their v card
taken rip you're inappropriate
R get out of here you're banned I know
it's 10:25 but all right what's
Happening Here 27 packs left good Pace I
like this people aren't stealing them
thank you everybody for being incredible
and letting the newbies get
in here we go people getting in this
might be it by the way this might be it
perfect okay we're gonna let we're let
we're gonna let anybody buy him if they
want got it this is
awesome everybody 15 14 13 get in if
you're new get in if you're new get your
first pack back pull a one1 share it
with us on Twitter uh everybody who's
bought tonight post hey V friends on
Twitter heyv friends and show them a
video of you and the kids if you don't
want to show your kids of you posting
your first open pack we will share it
and we'll encourage all the V friends
the hundreds of thousands of V friends
to follow you on Twitter so there's a
little fun Arbitrage to grow some social
media sold out yep that was very nice by
the way I really like what's going on
here very proud of people it's making me
want to give away something crazy before
we get out of here the cordialness the
graciousness the kindness like a kadu in
this room is amazing all right I'm
trying to get a sense here how many
people still have not gotten their first
pack and want to buy a pack put in need
a last pack type in need a last pack
because you weren't able to get one yet
and you're just figuring it out right
now need a last 5 six s still a good
amount yeah it's a good it's 300 was
like the exact right number it seems how
many people need a few minutes to create
their account put their credit card in
an address is that what you need put
need pack need time need time put that
cuz I want to get
people and does everybody know how to do
it yeah it seems like people are just
getting in need A5 pack no Killa we
don't have $5 packs I'm sorry we'll do
we'll doing free [__] all day though and
you free better than five free what's
better than five Zippo [__]
Zippo okay just added my info who needs
one more minute to add their info and
get their card in and get their address
in say one more minute one more minute
cuz I want to make sure everybody gets a
chance here might lose this right yeah
do this first yeah I think we're
right all right I think we're okay have
a Gary V rookie you do that's a good
education little something yeah okay
think we're good last 50 yep
go guys last 50 packs of the night are
live I'm not selling packs for less than
anymore and these are 30 right yeah I'm
not we should we can have a quick
meeting about like break spot pricing
and all that so the boxes would then be
390 I think boxes have to go to
300 they they went from 240 to 275 I
think boxes need to go to 300 we don't
but I'm talking about like when they buy
a random letter A to Z like we can talk
more about it well how much do you guys
sell for now at $25 pack value so 325 a
box that's it I mean look the OG's like
it's just supplying demand like we're
not this is it we I don't know who was
in the room with me shipping me earlier
but I I said some Al or not even just my
own opinion oh I saw the silver did did
you see the silver pies b games we have
a lot of updates coming up alpha alpha 4
hour meeting today what that they should
be worth more asked what I said earlier
today when we were we were just working
away what happened what did you say no I
told BR earlier I was like my opinion is
I think the CNC boxes are should be yeah
dude I'm super pissed that it's his
fault we're growing the universe we're
growing the UN all of you should right
now say thanks rips thanks rips in the
chat for what's been going on what what
uh are we done two spot I need you to
say thanks rips because all this 240 and
20 all this [__] that's been going
on is over the big bad wolf isn't
[__] sold out and that big bad wolf
is giving this away for now for free
I'll give you [__] for free but I'm not
going to [__] misprice this [__] and
it's mispriced and the the and you know
these are fresh boxes you know why of
course of course by the way big part
reason that eBay prices are a little
lower is people are scared that people
open them and repack them and all that
stuff we' throw me one of those Ezra our
shit's in the
[__] our [__] in the [__] car like
this is the one of ones and [__] like
none of the like this I'm telling you
we're making a mistake packs are now 30
and boxes are now 300 even toight it's
250 275 we did today I'm willing to do
some boxes at 300 right now put up five
boxes at 300 I'll show you
likew don't be a dick who wants a box
one box put one box who wants a box
which gets you three [__] two to
three we're putting up enough for less
than 1% of the community right now I
don't give a [__] I'm trying to show
your [__] face I understand I'm Al
I'm aligned with you I was being too
kind there's a lot of people I was being
naive is what I was being that's a
better word than kind yeah I'm going to
make a new be friend naive
[__] box for 300 now you should go to
eBay right now if you want box for Less
cuz that's it the [__] part's over
[__] the part's [__] over I
understand what
305 yeah I'm not joking around here 305
hey 305 a box yeah Dustin don't laugh
three [__] 05 entrepreneur winner com
soon true coming right after this we're
gonna sell David
who just won no he got a pin he bought a
pin box he bought a pin box he didn't
get it David Who David who go David
who this a [__] Bea is good for one
extra I'm good for it right now I'm
really good for it these are these are
good to go 305 30 a box what oh yeah
you're good you're
good I get concerned about over ready
it's it's gone yeah they're gone it was
right here it's right here it's
lower yeah yeah oh one of five remaining
Z five okay they're gone who got them
Jugger not jugut good [__] gold Idaho
Joe I've heard of before the other four
I've not Idaho Joe is The man sit with
me Jim is awesome we know him longtime
vriends member but the other three I
don't know Juggernaut yep
SSG and John John all right [__] it oh
too many too many Dodger fans g a crazy
card [__] it this is going for free
insert let's [__] go [__] it out of
10 Kershaw this is Kershaw's actual
signature here [__] this I got a big
idea oh
no give Bo live baby
giveaway is live oh we've been live for
four and a half hours certainly have
Chad who's been here since the start say
start if you've been here since the
start I need to see who's say start say
start wow we got a lot of starts let's
go Miami Mike I believe that's love I
think miam Mike I think Miami Mike was
watching us at the gym if I'm
remembering right I might have been
thinking of someone else but there's
someone like doing the freaking like
stuff
lats was a lot of people here since the
start starting for ever let's go Brandon
let's
go I got
stuff
U it's not all about vriends cards here
oh my God Blaster boxes Blaster boxes
with Gary V inserts bang you know what
would be so fun if we do pack R if you
hit a Gary insert you get something
special it' be so
cool Z Wilson special Zack
Wilson take
this
how much are these you want to look them
up real quick see what box goes for take
your guess I'm very I mean it's hard 50
bucks yeah yeah right in that ballpark
who
[Applause]
f349 that's a big card this is like very
big it's huge huge card farara
congratulations on that here's what we
got how much you're right 60 crossed out
58 crossed out 52 you're very right on
the money 55 probably 55 but what about
when that happens
56 all right the
hundo $100 you want to sell them
yep nah I don't want to sell them let's
give them away [__] the [__] there
you go I'm giving these we not selling
all of these I'm [__] giving these
away oh my God yeah I don't give a [__]
I told I told people that I wanted them
to have fun and come like I love these
people they're my community I'm not
selling this [__] I'm [__] giving
away one two three four five six lucky
number
seven does it all go in one person nope
one at a time that's seven minutes of
giveaways I don't give a [__] that it's
seven minutes of giveaways give them
away put this back in my office we go
let's go who like that kindness who lik
that kindness let's go chat who like
that kindness
[Applause]
you guys give those away while I go and
see how many of these
575 people are sharing this stream right
now on Twitter so that I can follow some
of them let's go chat 37
seconds rocket you've been
followed Killa coyote what happened to
your Twitter
get it you got to get a fresh one fresh
handle I love three heads
creating I [__] love them I'm
retweeting him on Twitter paying
attention to who's sharing player
culture you got to follow four
three wait Peg Moore is in here Peg what
about that $12,000 donation I gave you s
seconds yo what about the 12 thou if
you're new to this world you have no
idea the kindness that goes on here talk
about Peg more peg you're in here I just
saw you tweet tell them about the
$112,000 plus donation I made for you
12,350 based on V based on trash talk
scorpion.evo on here let's tell them
about Peg's 12,000 you think I'm being
nice here
$112,000 [__] LPS how about not
pulling it what is it LSPs what about
Delante Robinson just got a [__]
follow underscore what what about Derek
VCC just got a [__]
follow yep LS psor s congratulations
what about greasy Vision got a
[__] Nico got a [__] follow Japan
BC just got a [__]
follow Jessica ponzo's already followed
jaob
follow licensed plate girl know she's
got to follow already number two is live
Blondie followed I didn't realize I
thought Blondie was already followed I'm
excited about that he's Blondie by the
way I'm pissed that a lot of you don't
have [__] vriends pfps change your
[__] pfp to vriends right the [__]
ass a vri's card would be a cool pfp how
about that vri's card oh that's a cool
yes why don't we tell people when they
get their packs change your pfp pfp to a
be friend's card put tweet Ash vriends
pfp vriends pfp vriends card pfp hasht
be friends be
friends be friends card pfp as a hashtag
and then we find people I'm surprising
go like that I'm on it cuz a lot of you
are bullshitting I'm looking at all
these [__] pfps that are [__]
garbage Freddy you're [__] like
[__] no shot [__] Miss Marvel
you're followed like all sorts of H [__]
Brian May you're followed and Meanwhile
we're [__] winning at every one of
you you're [__] up I'm pissed look at
this cat dad Tech you're good Uno me
you're good Chris bar you're already
good and you have a be friends pfp
Harrison you're good because that little
kid stays you're good you and that
little kid are good Andrew Smith my [__]
Z Wilson wow I looked with two seconds
left I was Drew Wilson needs to change
to Zach not even the pfp just the first
name coost of the wood guys got to
change his [__] he looks kind he's a
good looking dude you might want to keep
your pfp but get a [__] vriend
there who's changing their pfp to a V's
card in the next 24 hours say change in
the chat who's doing it we have receipts
there we go Tyler any pull on that
giveway Cory let's [__] go there we
[__] go no there's one just
ended look at this people are coming
through cuz they love the kindness are
we giving away these boxes yeah Yep
they're all going I'll keep my phone out
wait I can't start it though I can't
start the next one 108 management you're
[__] in now bread you're [__] in
now people are sharing now tonight was a
nice night [__]
pumped what is going on it didn't pull a
winner for
me yeah it looks like the giveaway might
be the giveaway stuck at zero oh wait I
just got refreshed addition zero
see missfit inter yeah I never I never
got it either what's happening we having
a problem with ftic live is just a
little buggy how post podcast you just
got to follow possibly be I bet I'm
going to get a text from like four
people at fnatic live working on it dag
Fanatics live we're watching you Dior
Dior was upset because his uh shout out
Dior but just take he's watching us and
his [__] are getting sorry his
football team sorry his
commanders you can keep your pfp you
look like a [__] Do's a [__] male
model like you can't [__] change that
[__] it's Miami Mike I love so much I'm
a big Miami Mike guy Miami Mike's right
Miami mik I like Miami Mike's energy why
is that
happening Nicole Le you're in the sh K's
hair is epic you guys got it shiv sh
cryptonaut I
can't is that shiv I or a different sh
sh they got a pretty cool pfp all right
next one's going live ladies and
gentlemen Fanatics can barely handle the
giveaways we're crashing they can't
handle our they genuinely cannot handle
someone said sh Poland ship's using a US
you get a follow back so hold on Shi is
a good example of if he's from Poland
show sh tell the chat how
by the way these are super [__]
underrated the iconics there's more to
come like like look this was a great
profile switch J rob to the iconics J
rob do you own that iconic I think he
does actually what sh how did you win I
want to learn International did niik win
the [__] Vio Nico won it yes oh
that's a [__] amazing Nico the Vio
already has the card BF oh my God I love
that he's on the ball that's that's
called being on the ball Lord Lord chis
said jet suck Lord I don't know my
sister my sister's in Detroit address
got him if you see this man punch him in
the
dick piss here an international member
just won cuz they use their sisters
address in Detroit that's that's the win
but I'll follow Lord chis because I like
him Lord suck Lord CH the oh boy Danny
gotta follow this is exciting I've I've
really followed a bunch of people o Kyle
changed to a good one we got to run look
what Kyle changed this no I know this
one's still ending this it's it's
glitched out Z Wilson Oh Jared's getting
a follow all right let's see what this
commanders are 3020 now let's see if we
get a winner Dan oh I like look what Dan
did in the chat said SG did anyone uh oh
you're getting I got it in front of me
[Music]
c s c c kuas Scot c u s Dante congrats
on to the next one on to the next Stein
we are live Stein you got to change
this but you get a
follow o cow banga I love cow Bunga I
might be
the number four live wonder
what the real let's go chat the real
deal of the night was the 15minute
FaceTime and the Persian that was not
even close that person stole it that's
crazy in char yeah but like if if we
marketed that happening we get like real
entrepreneurs in here like trying to bid
but I'm pump they stole it's for it's
for the community who's here
100% I [__] love everybody I'm
looking look at this Kiona Dano I just
followed a fuckload of people how long
is this [__] taking it's a minute it's a
minute per yeah we can do the last plus
a few glitches that came about uh how
many people missed a pack for 30 bucks
I'm about to pump them to 35 did anybody
don't they're going to be
they're going to be 50 your [__]
before you turn 40 which is next week
um yeah me and [__] Dustin went to
People Want it people want it 40 a pack
Gary Dustin's [__] 39 years old we
went to clear and we like walked in
they're like are you by yourself and he
was Dustin was behind me we just were in
Florida had a talk I did and they're
like no I'm like I'm with this guy
they're like cool and the guy goes is he
a
minor guy's [__] 80 years old he
looks 14 know sign is really cool we
don't do that often yo Al oh Danny I
like what you did yo Al nice dub oh wee
I love you for that go 50 packs big
shout out and love yo Al let's go next
do you want to do three more or do you
want to do the last three in one what I
can tell you right now is I want to do
three more I want people to get free
[__] I [__] love this community with
all my [__] face so stoked from them
tell be friends relas I think I'm
pumping packs to 40 I think I'm just
skipping over
35 I'll pay 50 for a sign pack all day
signed is big
course hund you're
smart maybe next one's
live someone said I want a second pack
someone said 50 all day I will get a be
from one
day no I think P everybody what do you
think pack should be settling in
at 69 54 55 20 10 55 100 50 four cards
in a pack a th a thousand's right
155 30 45 25 average I'd say here is $40
is what should be 40 just yet it's four
cards so it's you know if it were eight
cards seven cards six cards sure five
cards 25 was a [__]
joke and the 240 boxes you sold the
other day I want to punch both of you
with
luck that who got a box for 240 the
other
day
gosh oh my God I kind of got it kind of
didn't um the caviar burn we were
talking about [__] the caviar burn on
book ginges is [__] crazy yeah like
you know and the winner
is Joey
t353 Joey T got to be sounds like a new
name to me no no it's not it's not Joey
t no repeating customer 240 bucks really
pissed me off rips I told you you did
I'm excited that there's a twer at the
end let's go somebody's getting a twer
let's go somebody's getting a TW tops s
two I really get excited about
auctions yeah auctions are fun Should I
auction something I'm trying to
findra you what I I we're doing a big
auction we redeemed himself drunk Ezra's
backun we're doing a huge [__] get
ready doing right now one of the biggest
right off my [__] wall I previewed it
earlier for the 599 of you here we
[__] go
the G's walking G's walking to the
wall he's a Serial entrepreneur if you
didn't know I cereal the podcast Puffs
he's looking for which one that he wants
off the vinner media
wall we got slug Gary
B
oh astronaut can you tell everybody how
these were gotten the V iconics are
profile pictures of the spectacular one
of one vfend series 1 nfts I think back
August watch this August 11th 2020 nice
job August 11th 2022 V friend
spectacular holders were air dropped the
iconics which is the new gong bogy one
of the earliest web 3 nft artists in
sports creative vend iconics he's like a
historical artist Gary got close to them
he made these they're very cool aird
drop for free as a spectacular surprise
yep spectacular surprise to Holders they
all got the nft one of one of their
color their exact token and now they're
Al it's the rarest spectacular are the
rarest forms you guys see them in one
of1 you see and CNC they're the 101's
this is the uh one1 physical
canvas do something cool on it I don't
know what that means rocket
ship
um oh
rocket ship you guys get that um this is
[__] insane what a good
signature we're auctioning this off this
is like a pretty yeah this is a pretty
rare item we're going to auction this
off o Chad who won that giveaway didn't
pull through for me I might have it do
you know why I'm auction this off
tonight I'm auctioning it right now
because I believe that I'm a buyer at 5K
to start I'm auctioning this Dar V
Darion V a r i o it's late d a r r i and
only the real hardcore are here so a lot
of people are missing this and I'm
pretty excited about
that if you want your first pack and
can't afford wow Bowser I would love to
share a pack with someone new find me on
Discord or here Bowser 0901 what a
nice uh yep you know what to do yep
you're setting that up yes sir we don't
even have Astro cards because they're so
rare comp uh title is Astro Auto also
throw this in fre new that's a new 10
yep just going to throw that in for free
don't don't get it reslab because the
auto will come off true keep it at the
95 just a little here we go we're going
to watch this off it's a canvas it's a
12 by 12 in canvas I've never given
these I did one time something I
remember but I feel like this is going
to be a lot of fun because this is one
of the biggest top 10 characters Auto
little sketch if you're long and what I
like about it is there's not going to be
a lot of competition it's not a very big
audience it's cool to put on your wall
which is nice to put in a [__] ball
here we go it said wall but I agree
actually write down what your prediction
is oh write down your prediction of what
the auction goes off at okay give me
this let's all three of us let's play
game see who's CL like I used I used to
love when we did this on like Google
meets
M I don't have a pen I
got it's good it's good I want a Sharpie
you got it all right here we go I got my
number I got my number I'm very hesitant
I'm I I already regret my number but
close yours here's mine wait here we go
fold it like this m is it too late too
late I regret my number vastly go con
man all right you going to put this up
for auction yep Ready yep let's show it
to the camera the camera and it comes
with the CB gold the gold comes with the
crab and the
crab let's go chat we're at five 8 620
640 660 680 700 740 760 820 840 this
could go more than your 15 minute face
can I like just rip my not 1350 1,400
can I just rip my post it up I don't
even want to 17 oh no 15 I didn't do
well I didn't do well 1500 how did the
who got the 15 minutes 1550 I don't
think people understand
2050 secret agent I mean this is Fu A
Sketch so waffles 2150
21 2250 bad bro it's
bad3 people saying I was thinking over
four someone said Krypto be JD Krypto
teacher says shees
2500 here 25 oh my gosh get the get Alex
lock gavl right now damn it JD Krypto JD
Krypto 2007 is that over yep over who
won JD crypto 2007 how much
2500 wait it's done done it says 25 for
us the next bid might have been 26 so
it's over yes JD crypto yes let's clap
it up for JD crypto
[Applause]
JD all right these two things go don't
forget our guesses about your guess no
listen they went higher none of us went
this High con man yeah no it was it was
bad one it was a bad what the
[__] I didn't know I've never s I've
never as soon as I wrote mine out I
regretted it cuz I knew it was
low
rips doesn't even do that I forgot a
zero at the
end5 that was the closest but like it
crushed even our honestly in hindsight
like that one's just never available
Auto like makes sense physical art I
bought some art last
Saturday um all right
I feel like I should give something
away give me that right there more give
me that these are all connected give me
one just give me one [__] the [__]
I'm getting away a sign box sign Box
open it nope okay sign box on the
outside it might be actually open in the
first place no it's not it's not all
right start off uh start the
free
wow wow show this camera after you're
done how about a
signbox sketch of the patient Pig with
the auto in the
mouth F kidding me are you [__]
kidding me for free for [__] get louder
[__] I mean this is what's
what's the date what's the date the date
is October 5 105 105
105 the time is oh con is the wrong time
10 not time stamping it 1053 no that's
fine I'm not doing that this is [__]
huge free auto box sealed Series 2
compete collect patient Pig with the
auto mouth patient Pig with the auto
mouth this box will never be open
probably not well it's it's oh what's
that
last BBC yeah if you know cards how many
people know BBC yeah that's right this
is really smart quarterback you send
this to BBC and get a seal Zack
Wilson man this is [__] enormous this
was a great way to end it this they
should probably get this in a slab PSA
cut it is another thing no I would bebc
this me too it's a box if they want to
rip the Box oh my God whoever wins this
got the [__] monster this could get
crazy G who g g
let's
[Applause]
go do we know GI never heard that right
here j l y g are you in here give us
your story do you own to be friend is
this your first time did you R me fall
on here gy give us some stuff Ezra
you're on it give me a big oinks in the
chat oink oink oink oink give me two
seconds wow [__] gy gy captain I can't
believe I just did can't wait to see
this on
S wow Pate 5K says New York that is that
is but he said that on the last one and
he didn't bid he's he's he's all talk I
should do an auction on a drawing on a
box of like just a comp what that just
happened but not today we'll do it
another that could be cool to every time
we go live how cool is that we should do
it every time honestly this is my
favorite collectible we've ever done
like here this is sick I think that's a
very unique one also how many people
feel this is better than the astronaut
just s up or astronaut say pig or
astronaut say in the comments pig or
astronaut a sealed box little Sports by
if we did this every time we went live
is [__] legit this is [__]
original it's original art we SE bro you
saw what the stuff went for chrisy like
this would you be against this when we
go live each time too much too much
wow um people want to buy a box how many
people want to what did I say box is
going to be
real five real 7 you're talking now or
next time we go
live all right I think we did a lot of
damage tonight I think we did pretty
well it's 1055 got five minutes
max why don't we take meaningful
feedback in the chat no actually I'm
gonna want you to tweet it but no boxes
200 okay so what do we decide boxes are
packs are 30 which brings it to 390 and
boxes are 305 that's a good discount
that's the I'm going to check eBay who
got smart and attacked you know I always
love to see who's [__] smart I love
on their toes yeah I want to know who
like went to eBay and [__] snagged up
I have another measurable yep I see
boxes [__] I see this every people
are [__] SM look at that look what
happened when people saw where we went
the last thing that we sold the last
thing sold before was a wizard Hollow so
let's see how much look what happened
people [__] I told you people [__]
I'm going to see another even smarter
people I'm going to see if I can find
some cool stuff socks here there we go
two [__] it's smart I'm GNA see if I can
find people who D listed oh wait show me
that you do you can see who ends things
no one's paying that much attention and
there's also not that many boxes well
that's what I'm trying to say like we
made 55 we that's a nice one there's
still active five five five five five
holders God from series two tell people
what we're looking at people don't even
know what this is this is V how many
people know what this is say yes or
no yes yes yes this is
friends this is the original imagine the
first time this this was the should we
do one right now I want to do a box we
don't have we have one here but we
do no you don't yes we do no you don't
everyone wants to go home I've been live
for 5 hours I want to do 24-hour live
been for 5
hours yeah boxes boxes are
finished somebody got that tonight right
right for me yeah yeah boxes are F and
we pulled one 500 out of I saw no we got
the we pulled one out we got no we got a
one out of 100 and last time we got the
500 out of 500 holy
[__] you doing it are you buying
it offer 225 I'm buying it are
you no it's getting shipped to my house
all right I'm
gonna I'm just oh wait uh oh no I think
I'm good
[__] this [__] I'm not let 250 I'm
buying
it let's see if you got it oh what
someone bought it before
you you [__] [__] oh wait someone
said I bought it first soggy waffles
soggy
waffles you got beat by soggy
waffles Mother stream
sniped that's
tough oh man the boxes are fresh too 29
they have
quantity
29 be DM two but that's with tax that's
like 3:30 right [__] my we have one I
want one so bad oh my
God they best offer make an offer will
sh him a message
boxes are finished on eBay after tonight
completely well there's just too many
people who didn't know about that who
needs a yeah this is what's happening
we're just I mean if people understood
we're [__] three minutes in how many
people right now watch this Be Friends
Community how many people right now just
starting to get a sense of what's going
on V friends and want to buy a series
one V friend vf1 if you are now actually
interested in buying a series one VF nft
put in vf1 put in vf1 in the chat watch
people don't get it wow yeah bro I'm
people don't the first that's the
establishment of the of the IP yeah
people understand rips I've been trying
to tell you I'm well aware
what what is
it can I slab it what is this can I slab
people don't understand we're just
starting to establish the idea if
someone else would get that actually
tattooed in like colored in can we o it
be like this is 101 handwritten remember
that nft story like someone selling
their skin through the blockchain there
was just something weird like that
should we give away see someone said I
100% wood that is so funny Whiskey
Jack dude that is good stuff dude I'm so
pissed about these boxes somebody
[__] what if we auction the Sharpie
that touched my neck someone just
offered me $700 for my signed rare robot
sticker on eBay wow yeah that makes
that's yeah that's
standard um oh my God another one oh no
I a stock that's the one I got [__] on
yeah that was wild soggy waffles got
you should we who needs a box who needs
a box
bad anybody wants one all right yeah all
right how many box do you want to sell
I'm probably go to
310 I'm I'm not sure
310 yeah bro I don't give a [__] Dustin
he was genuinely like very mad about PR
people don't understand we don't have
that much inventory people don't
understand um are you okay yeah what's
the matter I just had a question for
Adam about what this means but I think
we good it was weird last time too yeah
I think we're good yeah we are good okay
Alex 96 I don't see any for 250
oh boy my neck is signed by Gary ve it's
not even signed by Gary ve I don't even
have a
signature you got to do it right thank
you
thank this is going to be very
interesting I don't
have so
much that's that's the money shot I'm
hoping some people list
boxes I have Gary's autograph
[__] that's gone can I like take like a
tattoo and like get it onto the paper
from my I'm how many are you thinking 13
perfect yeah very perfect
313 3 $313 he's saying for 13 boxes 313
okay
gotta I wanted that
box you had a steal on the black cat box
the other like a while I got to steal on
the devil from Roman yeah he hooked it
up somebody got a box tonight for 22
look at your eay you buy a lot of stuff
non eBay though like it's a lot that's
the other thing it's like a big
community of card
people you bought a lot of really good
stuff lately I don't know if you how
much you want to show this is like
confidenti you don't confidentiy me [__]
oh somebody just snagged one a
[__] look at this
somebody got one on fanatic somebody got
one on stockx stockx is sneaky these
ones are ready ready yep 313 a box 13
boxes please let people I I don't I
don't trust [__] Tom cat but um
please let new people buy it who's not
yet yep who's new box who's buying one
at 313 right now please put new box in
the
chat one two three want please everyone
let these people get it like all right
go ahead you push it one two five bang
14 15 there's many more than 13 yeah
Viking they're not going to get less
Brother 15 16 there's a lot more than 13
five
four three oh back up to five people
have pays to back to back to two what
does that mean back to three it'll
fluctuate between availability because
the card like goes in and out if it's
like their first time buying off ftic
live sometimes their payment gets
flagged and their Bank like it's happen
Bank calls that's that's fit
though uh if you got cancelled or or
refunded based on what they just told me
um let me know if you just text your
bank back or applied or some of the
stuff you're talking about let me know
in the chat should be
okay
y people don't even know that there are
series one cards that's a good point all
right everybody bucks are 200 bucks in
stockx
I don't know if I believe it they got a
little bit of a big but I don't know if
I believe
it you know what a good place to Ming
boxes
I really I think they have
some yeah buy can you buy
this is that is that real it is no way
that's that would be [__] insane it's
it's interesting because it's not it's
like all for different variant of the
boxes there's 15 different boxes so I'm
sure there's a lot of listings and
people might get
confused I'm not educated enough on
stockx everyone please get educated look
at this box that's the [__] rare box
people I don't really what's that people
saying don't buy on stock well that's
like a whole people some people don't
like Sox they have authenticity checks
and that obviously someone asked me a
four like should I buy from E B I'm like
there's a great Community people
everyone like there's a lot of reliable
sellers but you can't go wrong buying
from V friend like there's an element of
sa sa and security that you don't get
elsewhere
but people are saying stock is bad I I
well no I get that I think that somebody
needs a wizard pack that's
signed little wizzy little little wizzy
GNA give you a little whiz
wizzy hulo whiz holder is that the tall
family in chat let's go back go down to
the
bottom some a lot of people still want
boxes people want playmats is a good
good meaning today people want
playmats Halloween pins the tech prints
oh so didn't win
anything Facebook has 100 P
Bo figure it out that's right we'll
sweep the floor no no let them sweep the
floor we're not doing [__] I wanted to
buy that 250 but like stay out of it
give got our boxes let people steal it
that are here tonight I ja coffee stick
because I've only seen one in I see one
in the office I know we have
some chat we did the other day a lot of
people were familiar with Gregory's
coffee which is cool
yep 200 box on stockx
sniped eight seconds left to enter guys
last chance we got a little z z Wilson
that was a premature exac totally that
was a premature exac totally
premature it's true all right for the 6
550 of you please as we wrap up right
now please people wanted this this is
nice I'm gonna give it to this person
wow yeah nice little deal is
Adrian D Liz 732 you are dead right
everybody thank you for being here we
got many more streams coming up when's
the next one um next Tuesday the 10th
and then the 11th with you no we have
it's the alpha with you 6 7 p.m. we'll
see you next week um we may do a popup
tomorrow cuz we're all hyped probably
not we have a lot of packing to do but
the reality is is that we love you we
hope you had fun tonight we wish you
well I need all 550 of you to tweet me
now on X Twitter with your feedback your
thoughts what you liked um your
highlights the recap I love you I hope
you had fun I'm going to eBay to try to
figure out some [__] because boxes are
310 330 what do we 313 313 boxer 3:15
going forward
minimum that's it the the the lid's been
popped off this people have had it wrong
the whole time we ended it tonight
that's what they get for getting but by
the way it's probably gonna that's what
they get for being part of the alpha
streams first and foremost what I like
is the next 48 hours on eBay where
people like thought it was yesterday
yeah and all the crew here um we love
you we got a lot coming up um hope you
had a lot of fun wish wish you well hope
you can re can you rewatch these stream
replays on ourl all day long you can
share share the replays have fun be
friendscards let me know how you liked
it on Twitter give me your feedback guys
by appreciate everyone support yeah
let's CL it
[Applause]
up and I can close this over I got to
do a concept that I think would be cool
we're live
oh
are we live Still d